[Musique]
Noa Manoir, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Alors Noa Manoir, j'ai 43 ans. Donc je
suis fonctionnaire de police affecté à
la direction interdépartementale de la
police aux frontières un service de
rétention administrative. J'ai passé une
un peu moins d'une dizaine d'années dans
ce qui s'appelait les renseignements
généraux. Donc pour le département de la
scène Saint-Lie, j'ai été affecté à la
formation générale puis à la lutte
contre le radicalisme et le terrorisme
jusqu'en 2016.
Terrorisme de de quel type ? Écoutez,
terrorisme islamiste, hein. Mais euh
bon, effectivement, on avait une section
qui était qui qui a quasiment disparu,
qui prenait en charge le terrorisme
Basque et Corse, mais dans Saint
Saint-Dé, on n'avait pas d'activité de
cet ordre-là. Voilà.
La France, elle en est où avec le risque
terroriste ? La comment ça se passe ?
Alors, il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui à
l'instant té, j'ai pas euh forcément
accès à toutes les informations. J'ai
euh des bribes d'informations, des j'ai
des échos et cetera de ce qui se passe
dans les murs des services. Mais
effectivement, bon euh je crois que la
menace euh elle est pas à évaluer, je
dirais, à l'intérieur du territoire
national. elle est plutôt euh je dirais
proportionnelle à ce qui se passe en
dehors de nos frontières puisque bon
naturellement on a deux entités qui peut
qui serait susceptible de représenter
une menace au plan du du terrorisme. Ce
serait naturellement Al-Qaïda qui est
matérialisé par Almosra ou Akmi. que
pour ce qui est de l'Afrique du Nord et
de l'Afrique en fait du Sahel hein de la
zone Sahel et l'État islamique qui est
naturellement est en voie de disparition
mais bon on a quand même des risques
résiduels donc du côté de de l'Irak de
de de la Syrie et naturellement des pays
limitrophes comme la Turquie on a pu le
constater notamment au Pays-Bas la
journée d'avantieream
quand on voit qu'il y a des détenus
radicalisés
qui sont potentiellement libérables dans
pas très longtemps
que l'institution pénitentiaire tire la
sonnette d'alarme ça à votre avis avec
votre expérience est-ce que ça
représente un risque à court terme ?
Disons que je sais pas si euh on a un
risque supérieur chez la population
carcérale ou chez les personnes en
liberté qui seraient entre guillemets
des électrons libres ou des soldats
dormants de de ces organisations. Euh
c'est pas quantifié euh quant à présent.
Maintenant euh bon euh je dirais que on
peut pas malheureusement contrôler euh
tous les facteurs et tous les risques.
Je dirais notamment avec dans ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'Europe d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'espace Schengen. On a même plus le
contrôle de nos frontières. Donc
naturellement nous on peut simplement
être garantité,
de nos méthodes de travail. Et
aujourd'hui effectivement, bon vous me
parliez du du milieu carcéral, il faut
savoir que le renseignement
pénitentiaire a été inauguré je crois en
mai 2016 si ma mémoire est bonne. C'est
c'est une institution qui est toute
jeune, qui a 2 ans. Alors que en France,
on a du terrorisme depuis les années 80
avec les filières notamment Abdouah Salé
si vous avez souvenir les attentats de
Tati et cetera. Donc on a mis
extrêmement longtemps à réagir. Donc
bon, c'est un problème de culture
administrative française. C'estàd que
bon par exemple j'ai j'ai des contacts à
l'ASDAT, des des des camarades je dirais
de de promotion et cetera qui ont été
affectés à l'ASDAT et ils me disent
qu'ils sont formés c'estàd qu' la France
paye le FBA américain pour venir
dispenser des formations d'infiltration
numérique de contreerrorisme et cetera à
la date française alors que eux sont
confrontés au terrorisme depuis a priori
2001. Bon, on a eu un attentat en 93 qui
était un épiphénomène he du point de vue
de de géopolitique. Mais en France, on a
quand même normalement ce serait à nous
d'aller dire bah voilà, on est confronté
aux terrorismes depuis les années 80, on
a quand même une certaine proximité avec
les pays d'Afrique du Nord, les pays
d'Afrique noire, le Moyen-Orient, euh t
tous les pays justement
de de la francophonie, si je puis dire.
Et donc cette culture, normalement, ce
sera à nous de l'exporter et aujourd'hui
les Américains arrivent à nous la
vendre. Donc je pense que effectivement
on a un vrai problème culturel, un vrai
problème de synthèse, un problème de
mémoire et bon j'ai absolument rien
contre nos amis ou nos homologues
américains. Mais vous voyez moi je
aujourd'hui en tant que policier
français, je suis quand même assez fier,
on va dire et j'accepte pas l'idée que
quelqu'un qui a 15 ans d'expérience tout
au plus dans cette matière vienne me
donner des leçons payantes. Vous voyez,
c'est voilà, c'est une question de
fierté française et malheureusement bah
factuellement c'est comme ça que ça se
passe aujourd'hui.
Le contrôle judiciaire, les fichesses,
c'est fait pour quoi ? C'est fait pour
décorer, c'est fait pour rassurer le
C'est deux choses différentes. Le
contrôle judiciaire, c'est donc ça
concerne des personnes qui font l'objet
d'une décision de justice puisqu'elle
est décidée soit par un magistrat, soit
par le juge de de liberté de la
détention. La fiche S, c'est une mesure
administrative, une mesure de
surveillance qui est prise par
l'autorité administrative, donc les
préfets, les directeurs centraux des des
des direction du renseignement,
c'estàdire territorial, des RPP, des
GSI. Donc c'est une mesure de
surveillance, c'est une mesure passive
où parfois le plus souvent d'ailleurs la
personne fichée S ne sait pas qu'elle
est fichée alors qu'en contrôle
judiciaire, vous êtes conscient de cette
mesure puisqu'elle vous a été notifiée
et justement elle est faite pour
restreindre votre liberté.
Est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez une
fiche S au-dessus des épaules ?
Moi je pense pas, très honnêtement, je
pense pas. Ça
ça pourrait arriver. On va dire que vous
voyez, on n'est pas une vacherie près de
la part des services de renseignement.
Mais très honnêtement, moi j'ai toujours
été transparent vis-à-vis de
l'administration. Justement, j'ai eu
écho de certaines rumeurs, voyez, un
moment où quand on a essayé de me
déstabiliser, on a fait allusion à ma
religion. Mais ça me, a priori, ça me
dérange pas parce que moi j'estime que
les surveillances, elles sont
préjudiciables aux personnes qui ont des
choses à se reprocher. Moi, je suis
parfaitement transparent. J'estime être
irréprochable, ça veut pas dire lisse ou
blanc. On a tous nos défauts de
caractère, de personnalité, mais euh a
priori, si l'administration a besoin de
savoir quoi que ce soit, elle m'écrit,
elle me contacte et je lui répond avec
grand plaisir. Maintenant, s'ils veulent
superviser mes déplacements à
l'étranger, mes documents, mes demandes
de documents administratifs ou quoi que
ce soit, il y a aucun souci. Vous voyez
la laaffiche S quand vous avez demandé
un passeport, ça borne à la mairie. La
mairie appelle la préfure dis attention,
un tel est venu demander un passeport.
Si la préfecture veut savoir quand je
vais renouveler mon passeport, je le lui
dis avec grand plaisir. Si elle veut
savoir quand est-ce que je vais prendre
l'avion pour aller en vacances, donc je
honnêtement, je pense pas être concerné.
Voilà. Après, je pourrais bon, je
pourrais le savoir mais ça m'a jamais
intéressé ou traversé l'esprit d'aller
vérifier d'aller taper mon nom FPR.
La déchéance de de nationalité, ça sert
à quelque chose ? Moi, j'ai été
auditionné par la commission
radicalisation qui avait été exigentée
par le député Pietra Centra après les
attentats de Charlie en 2015 et j'ai été
le premier alors j'invite tout le monde
à vérifier avant même le débat public à
me montrer partisan de cette mesure.
D'ailleurs, on a engagé on a déjà engagé
dans mon service des mesures de de
déchéance de nationalité à l'encontre de
deux leaders islamistes à l'époque.
C'est c'est dans le cadre de l'article
25, ce qu'on appelle l'article 25, on
avait des personnes en fait aujourd'hui
c'est applicable. La dégen de
nationalité, elle est prévue par
justement par la loi pour les personnes
qui ont été naturalisées
dans dans les 10 dernières années.
Au-delà de 10 ans, on peut plus
aujourd'hui procéder à à utiliser cette
procédure. En tout cas, moi j'avais été
partisan justement de l'extension de
cette prérogative notamment pour les
binationaux parce que on se rend bien
compte que la majorité des gens qui sont
passés à l'action en tout cas à l'époque
étaiit je dirais des repris de justice.
C'est que les Kachi étaient déjà passés
par la case prison. notamment l'un
d'entre eux en tout cas était ressorti.
Euh bon euh on avait eu aussi des
délinquants de droits commun mais bon
c'est c'est en tout cas on avait eu des
condamnés des personnes condamnées pour
terrorisme qui qui sont repassées à
l'action Burakim notamment de la filière
des but de Chumon. Donc moi j'avais
estimé à l'époque qu'aujourd'hui euh
qu'à l'époque en tout cas la loi la
législation antiterréoriste était
insuffisante pour pouvoir permettre de
de mettre les les personnes hors d'état
de nuire suffisamment longtemps et que à
terme effectivement bah pour des
personnes qui ne se revendiquaient pas
de la culture française qui souhaitaent
s'en prendre aux citoyens à leurs
concitoyens français et pas d'issue
d'autres issues possibles que
l'éloignement du territoire
naturellement ça ça me paraissait
d'ailleurs l'expérience l'a démontré
c'était c'était logique Mais
naturellement ça nécessita une réforme
de la Constitution qui bon qui était
quand même je dirais assez inédite dans
l'histoire de la 5e République et le
président Hollande a préféré reculer par
la suite. Je dis pas que j'ai été à
l'initiative du débat mais en tout cas
je l'avais mentionné à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Le verset du trône ça vous parle ?
Euh oui en arabe ce qu'on appelle ayat
al cé c'est un extrait de la sourate
numéro 2 dite la vache. Voilà. Bon, je
crois que il y a pas elle contient pas
d'éléments particulièrement subversifs à
ma connaissance. En tout cas, si c'est
celui auquel je pense.
C'est un verset de protection, c'est ça
?
Oui, tout à fait. Oui. Qui rappelle que
je crois en quelques mots que Dieu ne
dort pas, qu'il est entre guillemets
qu'il ne connaît ni songe ni sommeil,
qu'il est le maître du trône. Et
globalement, bon c'est c'est on va dire
que c'est purement théologique. Il y a
pas de dimension politique dans ce
verset. À ma connaissance en tout cas.
Comment on fait pour infiltrer un réseau
islamiste alors que c'est des frateries,
que c'est des gens qui se connaissent ?
Alors, il faut savoir que nous quand
j'ai fait une interview sur un média un
média concurrent, les gens disaient les
policiers Oui, bon, on se comprend, on
s'est compris, les gens vous disent
Balance infiltré et cetera. Il faut
savoir que moi j'ai jamais infiltré un
réseau islamiste. Alors, c'est un scoop
mais parce que les gens ont beaucoup de
fantasmes. Le FBI américain le fait.
C'estàd qu'on a des agents de police qui
infiltrent des réseaux de
narcotrafiquant, des réseaux djihadistes
et cetera. Nous en France, les douanes
le font effectivement pour le trafic de
stupéfiant. Ça c'est une culture qui est
restée chez les douiniers. Mais en
France, nous on n'infiltre pas. On
recrute des personnes dans la société
civile, c'est-à-dire des des bon
personnes, on a on a on a on a des
critères hein, parce que il y a des
personnes qui sont excluses de ce type
de recrutement, mais on recrute des
personnes que qu'on immatricule et qu'on
infiltre nous dans les réseaux. Mais
nous en fait, on manipule entre
guillemets au sens large du terme ces
personnes, c'est-à-dire qu'on leur
on leur donne des directives, des
objectifs, on recueille les informations
et cetera. Mais moi, à chaque fois que
je suis allé assister à une par exemple
à une réunion islamique, une conférence
ou quoi que ce soit, je suis toujours
allé voir l'organisateur en me
présentant "Bonjour, je suis Noa Manoir,
je j'appartiens à un tel service et je
viens aujourd'hui écouter votre
conférence, mais j'ai jamais infiltré de
façon entre guillemets voilà subversive
ou quoi que ce soit. euh de une
quelconque organisation. Je me suis
toujours présenté à ce qualité. J'ai
même j'avais même des cartes de visite
nominatives euh dans les que je
distribuais gracieusement en disant aux
gens bah si vous avez une quelconque
information quoi que soit n'hésitez pas
à me contacter. Voyez, il y a cette idée
de tromperie et cetera, elle existe pas
chez les fonctionnaires de police en
France.
Recruter une source, ça se passe comment
?
Il y a pas de de de process. Il y a une
procédure administrative mais qui est
postérieure, je dirais, au consentement
de collaboration de la source.
C'est-à-dire qu'on il y a il y a
effectivement des contreparties euh
des remises de peine, des tours de
regard. On a on a pas les services
administratif ont pas vraiment la main
sur la justice. En tout cas pas pas
après je dirais les décisions de
justice. Il y a des contacts avec le
parquet naturellement.
On couvre pas de délit, c'est on demande
pas aux gens de participer à des
activités délictuelles. Ça ça s'est
jamais fait. C'est qu'on peut pas dire
aux gens aller braquer une banque et
puis ensuite vous venez nous raconter
comment ça s'est passé. Euh je dirais
que c'est des mesures administratives de
facilitation, c'est-à-dire que ça peut
être une indulgence sur une décision du
tribunal du police ou du commissariat.
Ça peut être une facilité à obtenir des
titres de séjour. Ça peut être
un petit peu une contrepartie financière
mais qui reste quand même assez modique
hein par rapport à
ça dépend de du travail effectué mais
franchement
ça dépasse très très rarement vraiment
euh le millier d'euros. Très rarement
vraiment.
Millier d'euros c'est pourquoi ? C'est
par mission par mission accomplie.
Voilà.
Quel type de mission pour 1000 € ?
1000 € ce serait plutôt déjà ce serait
pas de l'ordre du service de
renseignement. Ce serait plutôt une
contrepartie qui serait octroyée par une
un service de police judiciaire. Vous
permettez de démanteler ou de retrouver
le préjudice d'une attaque à ma armée,
d'un braquage, d'un tournement. Donc il
y en a pour plusieurs millions d'euros.
vous bon euh
vous pouvez être indemnisé euh voilà
dans dans ce cadre là de quelques voilà
de quelques centaines ou quelques
milliers d'euros en fonction du montant
du préjudice mais c'est ça ça reste très
très exceptionnel. En général c'est
plutôt de l'ordre du dédommagement.
C'est de la main à la main. C'est une
enveloppe.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est des enveloppes.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce qu'on appelait euh
à l'époque les fonds secrets du du
Premier ministre. Donc il son c'est les
tout tout l'argent qui sert à rémunérer
les sources est issu justement de ces
fonds secrets et une gestion qui est de
ces fonds qui reste bah qui qui
clay il les aime bien non ? Écoutez, je
sais pas, j'ai pas eu accès à son
dossier, mais effectivement, j'ai cru
comprendre que que bon, il il y avait eu
effectivement quelque chose de cet
ordre-là sans aller chercher jusqu'à
Claude Guéan, mon ancien l'adjoint, mon
ancien chef de service à LAADRPP, a
d'ailleurs été euh fait l'objet d'une
mesure de répression administrative pour
avoir été euh pris la main dans le pot
de confiture euh après une utilisation
frauduleuse justement, de ses fonds.
Ça fait l'objet d'un article dans le
Parisien.
C'est quoi son nom ?
Monsieur Nicolas de Lef.
C'est celui qui a été à l'origine
d'ailleurs de mon départ entre autres
hein.
On on en reviendra.
On reviendra sur ce sujet là. Donc le le
donc la source recruter la source quand
vous levez un renard quand vous sentez
que ça va partir un peu en couille si je
peux me permettre
si vous voulez
comment se passe la la chaîne de
commandement
en général en général on n'aime pas trop
entendre les mauvaises nouvelles dans la
chaîne de commandement.
J'en fais pas partie, j'en ai jamais
fait partie. Donc je sais pas comment
c'est reçu. Mais effectivement euh bon,
il y a ce que j'avais appelé le le
syndrome du médecin annonciateur.
C'est-à-dire que vous annoncez des
nouvelles, bon après elles sont
naturellement
recoupées hein, parce que vous vous
obtenez une information, il faut la
recouper, il faut la vérifier. Ensuite,
il y a une il y a un curseur. Il y a
toujours un curseur avec une évaluation
justement de l'information, une
évaluation du risque. Et effectivement
les les décisions de de d'action de
missillance, c'était pas de mon niveau.
C'est-à-dire que vous arrivez, vous
dites "Bah voilà, on a eu telle
information, telle rumeur. Parce que le
renseignement de toute façon, c'est
toujours je dirais la captation des
rumeurs en quelque sorte. Et ensuite bah
il y a les les surveillances elles sont
extrêmement onéreuses. C'està-dire que
quand vous mobilisez une équipe, un
véhicule type sous-marin, une équipe
vidéo, une équipe photo, une écoute
téléphonique, une surveillance
numérique, ça a quand même un coût et
donc il y a aussi le risque que la
surveillance soit pas concluante et
ensuite il faut en assumer la
responsabilité parce que quand vous
mobilisez des moyens sur une cible, ben
il y a peut-être une cible ailleurs qui
vous a été signalée et qui elle par
contre risque de passer à l'action. Et
donc il y a un travail de décision et le
le service de renseignement c'est un
service d'aide à la décision mais la
décision est toujours de l'ordre bah au
minimum des préfets, des chefs de
services, des chefs de direction et euh
voire du politique parfois.
Les points chauds en France, les poches
les poches de terrorisme ou les poches
de réseau islamistes en France, c'est où
? C'est Ver Nî, c'est Marseille, c'est
Paris. Je dirais que disons queour
disons qu'il y en a j'ai envie de vous
dire qu'il y en a pas. C'est ça. Ce
serait trop simple de dire que ça se
passe à tel endroit ou ailleurs.
Aujourd'hui, je dirais avec l'évolution
du numérique
notamment des chaînes cryptées, des
formes de discussion, des réseaux
sociaux,
voilà, on s'est aperçu que
bon, ça pouvait émaner de partout hein.
Si vous prenez le cas par exemple de AEN
B, celui qui avait tenté un moment de
mettre feu de mettre le feu d'incendie
avec des bouteilles de gaz, une cage
d'escalier dans un un immeuble du 16e
arrondissement, bon, il habitait une
campagne de Laesson. C'est un village
qui était géré par une zone par une
gendarmerie vraiment un village de
quelques centaines d'habitants et
pourtant le message de l'État islamique
avait réussi à lui parvenir à l'époque.
Donc on s'aperçoit que ça a aussi
concerné des personnes dans des banlieux
mais dans des villes assez éloignées.
Maintenant, sur les filières de départ,
on avait eu Lunel dans les ROS qui avait
été particulièrement concerné, mais on
avait la filière de Clichi Sousbois la
surmarne qui avait aussi euh
qui qui avait quand même été assez
qui avait d'un point de vue numérique
qui avait concerné quand même pas mal de
monde et après bon bah naturellement les
toutes les grandes villes mais je crois
que c'est un phénomène aujourd'hui en
tout cas au point de vue numérique qui
est plutôt derrière nous que devant nous
he les départs en Syrie et cetera, c'est
plus trop d'actualité.
Les les méthodes de communication entre
terroristes entre terroristes, c'est
quoi ? C'est c'est du down grade
technologique. C'est une carte une clé
USB, c'est un message qui est fractionné
entre trois personnes.
Ici vous parlez en sur le territoire
français ou
sur le territoire français et c'est dire
un message de l'étranger qui est expédié
en France. Est-ce que c'est comme avant
? C'està dire qu'il fractionne le
message en trois personnes et si vous
avez pas les trois personnes, vous avez
pas le message, c'est de laisser des
laisser laisser laisser des messages sur
des forums de discussion, sur des formes
de jeux vidéos. sur les formes de
chiens, sur les formes de toilettage
pour chiens. C'est
je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de
fantasmes. Bon, à un moment, je sais que
dans les au début des années 2000, on
avait eu je crois la presse c'était
emparé d'un d'un sujet je crois dans
lequel on avait un CD de Carla Bruni
dans lequel était renfermé un message.
Je sais pas si ça vous évoque quelque
chose. Bon, je crois que tout ça, vous
savez le le côté un peu James Bond, je
crois qu'il est de l'ordre du fantasme.
Aujourd'hui, ils se prennent plus autant
la tête. C'est-à-dire que ils ont des
des des forums de discussion, ils
animent des chaînes Telegram par exemple
et ils disent "Bon ben voilà, tu prends
un couteau à pain, tu vas à la gare R la
plus près de chez toi et puis tu plantes
un maximum de monde et puis ça se fait
dans les 24 heures quoi globalement. Euh
je crois qu'après tout le côté
espionnage et cetera, il est plus de
l'ordre du fantasme qu'autre chose.
Après effectivement quand vous avez de
l'armement lourd comme sur ce qui
s'était passé sur le dossier Glam, euh
il y a des messages qui passent via les
chaînes cryptées en disant bah voilà, il
y a telle adresse, vous avez trouvé bah
à l'époque c'était Net Sousois, une
Mégane dans le coffre, voilà, des armes
lourdes à récupérer. Bon là, il y avait
effectivement des communications de cet
ordre là, mais je pense qu'ils ont
compris que les chaînes étaient
infiltrées aussi et que naturellement,
bon aujourd'hui, c'est des portables
jetable, c'est-à-dire des puces à usage
unique où ils envoient un message par
puce, on avait vu pour le 13 novembre
par exemple et puis ensuite ils jettent
le portable à la poubelle. Donc comme
ça, le numéro est difficile à
intercepter voire impossible à
intercepter en tout cas à l'avance. Et
donc il y a des communications qui se
font de cet ordre-là. Après, c'est
quelque chose qui évolue sans cesse.
Moi, j'y suis plus depuis un bon moment,
donc naturellement ça a peut-être évolué
entre-temps.
Mera l'infiltration, il a bien baisé.
C'est pas le seul hein. Moi aujourd'hui,
si vous voulez, c'est un peu une douleur
en fait que que je ressens à titre
personnel
parce que moi je voyez bah aujourd'hui
j'ai lu la presse notamment l'actualité
des services pénitentiaires et puis vous
apercevez que celui qui est passé
Michaell Kyolo qui est passé à l'acte la
semaine dernière contre des surveillants
en péniten
la veille
les services de renseignement avaient la
possibilité d'intercepter des
communications qui li préparations
justement de de cet acte et a priori il
était prévu autre chose. Il devait s'en
prendre je crois du personnel d'enquête
sociale ou je ne sais quoi et il a
avancé son projet d'attentat mais la
veille il y avait eu effectivement des
discussions qui avaient été interceptées
mais pas écouté suffisamment à temps.
C'estàd qu'elles ont été écoutées le
lendemain du passage à l'acte. Et donc
c'est ce qui a permis de mettre en œuvre
mettre en évidence en tout cas des
complicités notamment celles de de de
monsieur B qui était je crois qu'il
faisait partie de la filière C torsi qui
était incarcéré dans le dans la même
prison.
Et donc Jérémy B, il me semble qui est
originaire de Sénémarne.
Et donc on s'aperçoit que finalement il
y a eu un manque de réactivité euh des
services de renseignement. Je sais pas
si c'est le renseignement pénitentiaire
ou le renseignement intérieur mais qui a
encore permis bon mais après on pourra
revenir là-dessus mais Charlie Hebdo,
c'est exactement la même chose. Euh le
comment dire Saint-Étienne du Rouvret
pareil. Donc à chaque fois finalement on
s'est aperçu qu'il y a eu des cont-temps
qui ont qui ont malheureusement, je vais
pas dire des négligences peut-être
parfois des contetemps, mais qui ont qui
ont permis que ce type de choses arrive
alors que dans la période actuelle on
devrait cadenasser, verrouiller, faire
preuve d'une réactivité exemplaire. Mais
euh vous voyez euh on a eu quand il y a
un problème de d'ordre public, c'est bon
quelque chose qui concerne directement
la population, qui est visible par la
population, bon ben la réactivité, elle
se fait pas attendre. dans les 48
heures, on remplace le préfet, le
directeur de de de de la sécurité
publique, de l'ordre public et cetera.
Mais dans le renseignement, on n'a pas
eu cette réactivité. Dans le
renseignement et on a on a cumulé les
échecs, c'est clair et net. Moi, je vous
le dis, hein, très clairement, il suffit
de prendre les dossiers, de savoir
quelles étaient les informations à la
disposition. Oui, mais elles sont même
dans la presse sur Charlie Hebdo, sur on
voit qu'il y avait quand même des
raisons de se soucier de de ce qui
pouvait se passer et euh il y a pas eu
les réactions appropriées et euh
naturellement bon bah si les personnes
en tout cas qui sont à la tête des
services de renseignement ont le
sentiment que de toute façon que ça se
fasse ou pas que qui se passera pas
grand-chose, bah naturellement il y a
aucune raison que ça change. Vous voyez,
il moi je pense que le politique avait
quand même et l'opinion publique avait
quand même des comptes à demander à ces
personnes, notamment mon ancien service,
laADRPP Paris, la petite couronne dans
lesquels dans laquelle en tout cas les
attentats ont quand même connu
un je vais pas dire un succès parce que
ce c'est c'est un terme trop positif
pour être employé dans ce cadre là, mais
bon, les attentats on ont pu être menés
à terme en tout cas.
Est-ce que le notre force de
renseignement s'appuie sur nos anciennes
colonies et sur nos anciennes
Non, alors il y a des légendes urbaines,
c'est-à-dire que par exemple, on vous
dit que le Maroc a aidé à la
localisation d'Abdamid Baou, ce qui est
totalement faux. On sait très bien
aujourd'hui rétrospectivement que la
formation vient d'un témoin qu'elle a
été traitée par l'ASDAT donc et qu'il a
que que Kababa a été localisé surveillé
par
une équipe de deux fonctionnaires
d'ailleurs de l'ASdat dont l'un a été
laminé j'ai j'ai appris ça par voie de
presse par le parisien donc
fonctionnaire d'origine maghrébine qui a
permis la localisation justement
d'Abdamida Baou et qui a été
complètement laminé administrativement
et au plan judiciaire Euh
pourquoi
a priori euh alors pour ce que j'en ai
lu dans la presse, on lui reproche
d'avoir vendu, je crois un véhicule à un
boucher. Boucher, je crois été mis sur
écoute dans le cadre d'une affaire de
trafic de stupéfiant et il aurait
mentionné qu'il connaissait un policier
qui aurait permis qui lui aurait permis
quelques facilités moyennance et donc ce
policier a été relié justement à cette
écoute via cette transaction la vente du
véhicule et donc il a été depuis mise à
pied laminé et cetera donc alors que
c'est lui qui a été reconnu comme étant
à l'origine de la localisation justement
du clan à Baou et qui a pu empêcher euh
son passage à l'acte à la défense qui
était prévu pour le lendemain.
Donc là, il y a il y a on s'appuie pas
sur notre sur nos anciennes colonies,
sur notre immigration, sur notre sur nos
jaunes de banlieu qui sont je faisais la
comparaison avec les États-Unis tout à
l'heure, c'estàdire que les États-Unis,
eux, avaient pas justement ce capital
humain
qui leur permettait
à la fois d'infiltrer puisque eux c'est
leur culture, mais également de bah de
mener leurs opérations à l'extérieur. Et
donc ils ont dû naturaliser à tour de
bras des personnes pour justement les
mettre à contribution. En France, on
avait le capital humain mais par contre
c'est l'inverse. C'est-à-dire que on a
préféré avoir une réaction épidermique,
se méfier et parfois je dirais exfiltrer
justement des services publics toutes
les personnes qui pouvaient être issues
justement des anciennes colonies.
vraiment clairement si vous regardez
pour ce que j'en sais si on prenait on
élaborait une statistique sur le nombre
de déshabilitation de refus
d'habilitation secret défense sur les
dernières années, je pense que les noms
à consonance maghrébine ou africaine
serait pour pas dire majoritaire mais
extrêmement présent dans dans dans dans
les listes.
C'est quoi ? C'est parce qu'il y a du
racisme, c'est de la méfiance parce que
pour reprendre certaines expressions
passistes, ils sont un peu trop basanés.
Non, parce que je pense que clairement
alors il faut
musulmans
il faut pas se mentir clairement quand
on quand on vous dit euh aujourd'hui en
tout cas le discours de la majorité des
hommes politiques vous disent l'islam
est étranger au terrorisme à l'islamisme
c'est une religion de paix et d'amour
ils le disent mais personne le pense
aujourd'hui. tout le monde fait un lien
direct en tout cas dans les actes entre
l'islam et le terrorisme très
clairement. Donc aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes musulman, vous êtes suspect de de
de collusion avec tous les organes de
justement idéologiques et cetera, tous
les vecteurs d'islamisme ou de
terrorisme. C'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous mangez avec vos collègues, vous
mangez du poisson, on se dit "Ah
celui-là il mange à l'al c'est bon la
coincé s'en est un." Vous voyez c'est
comme ça que ça se passe. Et c'est
stupide une takia ça se fait. Non
non mais aujourd'hui la question la la
takia c'est la c'est un concept qui qui
est revenu un petit peu à la mode sur
les réseaux sociaux qui qui évoque la
dissimulation c'est-à-dire en temps de
guerre à la base à la base c'était la
dissimulation parce que bah quand vous
aviez il y avait un risque vital je
prends l'exemple par exemple de
l'ancienne Andalousie ou quoi que ce
soit où il y avait un risque vital du
fait d'être musulman c'estàd vous étiez
musulmans vous étiez éventuellement soit
forcé à vous convertir sur décapités bon
vous étiez autorisé selon la législation
islamique à changer de religion
officiellement mais à secrètement rester
était musulman. Voyez, c'était c'était
ça le concept de Takia. Aujourd'hui, ça
a été détourné dans le sens où
finalement il faut même les gens non
pratiquant du du fait que de leurs
origines étrangères seraient suspect
justement d'être d'adhérer à l'idéologie
islamiste
malgré leur apparence. C'estàdire
toujours se méfier d'un en gros d'un
arabe ou d'un noir.
Si bien qu'il soit musulman justement,
attention soit peu qu'il soit musulman.
C'est pour ça que les terroristes du 11
septembre la veille se taper des rails
de coqu et des [__]
Je sais pas, franchement, je connais pas
du tout ce dossier. Mais bon, de toute
façon, je vais pas faire de
je vais pas je vais pas tenir de propos
de globalisant ou quoi que ce soit, mais
si vous allez sur les Champsélysées ou
ailleurs dans les si vous fréquentez les
nuits parisiennes, essayez de voir qui
se tape des rails de cque et des [__]
bon, ce sera pas très éloigné de voilà
en terme de profil des personnes qui ont
perpétré attentat du jour 11 septembre
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Voilà. par quoi des des des saoudiens ?
Oh,
je vais pas nommer, je vais pas je vais
pas me faire d'ennemis gratuitement, on
va dire. Voilà. Mais bon, c'est un
public majoritairement moyenne-oriental
si vous voulez. Voilà, aujourd'hui parce
qu'en fait
c'est les mêmes qui font leur marché au
Liban.
Je sais pas, je je connais pas du tout
l'actualité du Liban. Mais si vous
voulez, globalement,
moi, vous voyez, je suis issu d'une
famille musulmane.
Quelle origine ? algérienne
algérienne
et euh il y a un moment j'ai été levé en
cité dans ce milieu. J'ai j'ai voilà
j'ai écouté le discours en étant
adolescent. J'ai forcément de du des
prêcheurs. C'est c'est quelque chose que
je connais. C'est une ça fait partie de
la culture des cités.
Et vous avez appris l'arabe littéraire
où ?
En Égypte. J'ai fait plusieurs voyages
en Égypte et c'était aussi ma deuxième
langue vivante au collège et au lycée.
Et euh et donc c'est la République qui
m'a enseigné la langue arabe. C'est pas
mes parents ou mes ou mes aïeux ou quoi
que ce soit.
Vous avez été faire quoi en Égypte ?
C'était à l'époque j'étais
j'étais dans le milieu sportif en fait
et je suis allé
au nord dans le sud
euh c'est plutôt dans le sud de l'Égypte
le le Sinaï parce que c'est au bord en
bord de mes rouges parce que j'étais
j'étais adopte adepte de plonger
sous-marine. Tu
même. Tu même. Anatas.
Ouais, c'est bon. C'est bon. Bref, je
vais je vais pas m'étendre sur mes
vacances en Égypte à l'époque. C'était
des vacances he c'était et donc j'étais
adepte de plonger sous-marine et
Ratas.
Ratas, qu'est-ce que ça signifie ?
Plongeur.
Plongeur. D'accord. Voyez, vous
m'apprenez un mot. Vous aussi vous êtes
plongeur, c'est ça ? D'accord. Donc euh
donc naturellement euh comment dire ? Je
je suis allé à l'époque pour des raisons
des des raisons personnelles. C'estàd
que j'aimais beaucoup le la plongée
sous-marine et cetera. C'était le seul
endroit aussi où même le 30 décembre
vous aviez 30°gr. Donc ça permettait un
dépaysement. Et naturellement quand je
suis arrivé en Égypte bah il parlait pas
français là-bas parce que c'est pas une
ancienne colonie française. En tout cas,
il y avait une présence française mais
quand vous leur parlez français, ils
comprennent pas à la différence du
Maghreb. Et donc naturellement, ils
m'ont forcé entre guillemets pour
pouvoir communiquer à parler arabe. Et
donc comme j'ai j'avais multiplié les
séjours, j'y suis allé 5 si fois. Euh
naturellement, j'ai pu me me
familiariser avec le dialecte
Moyen-Oriental. Et bon, après, ça a été
quelque chose que j'ai pu valoriser
aussi dans les services de
renseignement, mais en France, c'est un
dial qui reste assez peu utilisé he même
même dans les milieux culturels ou quoi
que ce soit. C'est majoritairement des
maghrébins honnêtement.
On en était où ? La question c'était
quoi ?
Je me souviens plus. On a ouvert des
fenêtres Windows entre-temps.
Oui. On va revenir sur le terrorisme.
L'État français protège-t-il
correctement la France ?
Je sais pas. Je dirais dans les limites
de ce qui est devenu aujourd'hui
l'Europe de Mastrich. Ça me paraît assez
difficile parce que bon par exemple vous
prenez un exemple c'està-dire que
l'attentat
qui a d'ailleurs abouti
euh du Talis donc le celui qu'on
appelait Ayou Alkazani.
Donc il était citoyen marocain. Il est
arrivé clandestinement en Espagne. Il
s'est radicalisé en Espagne au contact a
priori de bon d'islamistes espagnols.
L'Espagne le repère les services de
renseignement le repère le trace et il
fuit pendant 6 mois. vers Aubervilier,
donc en Saintsy, il séjourne 6 mois au
Bervilier et l'Espagne prend
connaissance de son départ vers la
France et le signale à la France. Bon,
c'était à l'époque où je travaillais
Saint-Sandy, j'ai jamais entendu parler,
j'ai jamais reçu à titre personnel le
signalement des espagnols. Ça veut pas
dire qu'il a pas eu lieu. Je peut-être
qu'il a été transmis à notre service,
peut-être qu'il a été transmis à ma
hiérarchie mais que pour certaines
raisons, il m'a pas été relayé. Mais en
tout cas, j'ai pas entendu parler de
lui. Donc au bout des 6 mois, il va en
Belgique et bon, en fait, vous
connaissez la suite. Euh alors qu'on a
là, on parle de pays euh qui sont euh
des pays de de l'espace Schengen
justement. Donc le fait qu'on ait pas pu
centraliser justement les fichiers euh
au plan européen, je dirais que a priori
ça relève de l'abération. C'est-à-dire
queeffectivement, il y a le secret
défense, il y a le secret euh euh des
des fichiers et cetera, le secret
professionnel, mais le fait qu'un
individu fiché en Espagne puisse
circuler librement en France, il s'est
journé à aller en Belgique et perpétrer
un attentat sur le sol français, ça
c'est ça ça paraît assez inexplicable en
fait en quelque sorte. passe un peu pour
des gros consire ça les fait marrer les
islamistes qu'on puisse rentrer, sortir
je suis pas sûr qu'ils en rent beaucoup
mais je pense que c'est des gens qui
profitent justement des faiblesses de
notre système et voilà perpétuellement
c'est ça c'est-à-dire que bon vous avez
un système vous avez une forteresse et
puis s'il suffit qu'il y ait un trou de
souris et puis il se faufile à
l'intérieur tout simplement et
aujourd'hui c'est pas un trou de souris
c'est un gruère honnêtement qu'est-ce
qui empêche quelqu'un aujourd'hui de
conditionner un jeune sur une chaîne
télégram bah vas-y prends ta caisse et
puis fonce dans la foule Voilà, c'est si
vous voulez on pourra on pourra mettre
des plots de béton un petit peu partout
devant tous les marchés, les barrières
et cetera, mais on pourra jamais
atteindre un niveau de sécurité absolu.
que ce qu'il faut aller chercher a
priori c'est effectivement
en fait c'est un travail colossal c'est
qu'il y a un travail d'éducation à faire
mais il a aussi un travail de lutte
contre le racisme et notamment ce que
j'appelle ce que certains appellent
l'islamophobie mais bon le racisme
antimusulman parce que bah c'est c'est
aussi
un des terra justement du je dirais de
de de de du radicalisme. C'estd que
quand quand un pour en savoir quelque
chose quand un islamiste ve en doctrine
un jeune, il dit bah regarde tu es né en
France, tes parents sont nés en France,
regarde ton père il est là, il est
ouvrier du bâtiment, ça fait 30 ans
qu'il est là, il baisse la tête, il
ferme sa gueule, il bosse et regarde
qu'est-ce qu'on lui donne en échange. On
continue à l'écraser et tous les mecs
qui sont arrivés après lui lui sont
passés dessus. Voilà. Et toi, regarde
ton avenir. Tu es allé à l'école, tu
étais bon mais on t'a envoyé en filière
professionnelle, tu es en CAP
aujourd'hui, regarde, tu veux passer un
concours, on t'explique même quand tu
réussis, il y a une enquête de moralité
parce que ton frère a fait une connerie
à 20 ans, bah on te refuse
l'habilitation, on te refuse le truc.
Voilà, on t'aime pas, tu es pas chez toi
ici, c'est tu peux dire ce que tu veux,
tu es pas français, regarde, nous on va
t'accueillir, viens et cetera. Et donc
justement
c'est un discours qui a trouvé à certain
écho, certaines jeunesses. Quand je
travaillais en 20142 2015, il y a des
jeunes qui partaient en série qui
disaient "Bah tu viens là-bas, une jeune
fille qui se marie. On lui trouve son
prince charmant sur place. Les mariages
étaient primés 700 dollars. Les mecs
forçaient les les portes des maisons de
la diaspora syrienne qui était installée
à l'étranger. Donc c'était des baraques
avec piscine avec 20 chambres, des
riades et cetera où il disait bah tiens
voilà on a forcé la porte c'est à toi.
Voilà tu as 700 balles pour commencer et
ensuite comme en guise de carte bleue tu
as un kalashnikov et puis s'il y a un
commerçant syrien qui est un petit peu
récal citron bah tu lu en colles une.
Mais en général il donne la marchandise
sans trop discuter. Bon bah quand vous
êtes en France dans une cité vous dormez
à qu dans une chambre vous avez pas de
boulot on vous ferme toutes les portes.
Bon bah, c'est un discours qui a trouvé
un certain écho à l'époque d'ailleurs un
peu encouragé par la diplomatie
française puisqu'on vous expliquait même
jusqu'ici que Assad était vraiment un
dictateur à faire tomber et cetera par
tous les moyens. Bon bah naturellement
des des jeunes à cette époque en tout
cas on pensait qu'ils avaient la
bénédiction de de l'État français pour
pouvoir partir sur zone.
C'est lourd hein.
Bah moi je prends ça avec une certaine
légèreté parce que mon boulot c'est la
France. ce qui se passe à l'extérieur,
c'est effectivement dramatique. Euh,
d'ailleurs, c'est une posture qui a été
souvent comprise par des gens de mon
entourage et cetera qui disaient "Tiens,
tu es tu es pas solidaire de la
Palestine, de de l'Algérie, du Maroc et
cetera." J'aurais dit "Bah non, mais
c'est pour moi c'est secondaire. Moi mon
boulot c'est la sécurité intérieure.
Après, à l'extérieur c'est important
mais c'est il y a d'autres personnes
payées pour ça."
Il y a de l'infiltration islamiste dans
les forces de l'ordre, dans l'armée.
Ça arrive mais c'est extrêmement
l'armée, je sais pas. Bon mais c'est en
tout cas dans les forces de l'ordre, on
a eu deux cas significatifs. Bon après
il y a un fantasme qui parle d'une
trentaine de personnes et cetera. Après,
les dossiers sont à éplucher, mais
franchement, je crois pas qu'il y a eu
de danger immédiat. Bon, j'ai eu
connaissance d'un ou deux cas, c'était
même un peu limite, c'était un peu du
baratin. Bon, moi vous savez, je vous ai
dit que j'étais d'origine algérienne
dans les années 90 quand on avait eu des
soucis sur le territoire algérien, ben
quand un gars avait un problème de
voisinage depuis quelques années pour
parce que le mur était un peu trop ou
quoi que ce soit, il allait voir la
police et il disait "Attention, il est
sorti, il a discuté en arabe, il a dit
Allah Akbar et cetera." Voyez, même en
Algérie se faisait. Donc en France, ça
arrive. C'est-à-dire que quand on veut
tuer son chien, on dit qu'il a la rage.
Donc je pense que la police est une une
organisation pour le coup euh
infiltré avant tout par l'extrême droite
avant d'être infiltré par l'islamisme ou
tout ce que vous voulez. Et
naturellement, je suis en bonne position
pour savoir qu'aux yeux de quelques
collègues, les fonctionnaires d'origine
maghrébine ne sont n'y sont pas toujours
les bienvenus. Et c'est un petit peu
facile de de porter ce type
d'accusation. Ça existe. On a eu un cas
le cas d'un fonctionnaire d'origine
africaine euh au créelin bicètre qui
clairement a partagé des fichiers et
cetera qui faisait l'apologie euh je
crois de l'attentat de Mananville et
donc c'était inadmissible. Donc il a été
condamné et placé en détention pour ses
raisons. On a eu également une personne
qui a dû, je crois, être infiltrée par
je dirais, c'était pas son plein gré,
c'était une personne de du fort de Roni,
je crois, une française convertie à
l'Islam qui fréquentait un proche de
Koulibali qui qui je crois qu' qui avait
noué une relation amoureuse avec cette
personne et donc qui avait été écarté
des services de gendarmerie. Après le
reste, on vous dira toujours que il y a
eu un tel, un tel, un tel. Mais ça, je
crois que c'est c'est pareil, il y a une
instrumentalisation de ce type
d'information. Euh par exemple, le jour
où on a voté la loi euh dite colon, vous
savez la la le texte sur l'état
d'urgence, je crois que c'était le 23
octobre 2017 de mémoire, donc la loi du
23 octobre 2017.
Euh bah ce jour-là, c'est que la loi a
été votée un lundi, le vendredi, on vous
dit attention, il y a un type qui qui
finit sa scolarité, la 245e promotion de
gardien de la paix, c'est un ancien ADS
qui est fiché qui avait été fiché S
pendant 3 ans. Donc on nous sort comme
ça. Bon, OK, très bien. Donc moi, je
décortique l'information. Je le connais
pas le type, je sais pas qui c'est. Donc
je regarde et on s'aperçoit quand il a
été à DS, il a fait l'objet de
signalement de la part de ses collègues.
Ils l'ont placé, ils l'ont fiché S
pendant 3 ans, ils l'ont surveillé, ils
l'ont collé. Ils ont rien trouvé. Donc
ils ont levé le fichage et en fait il a
passé son courage de la paix, il l'a
réussi. Il y a une enquête de moralité
des services de renseignement.
Comment ça se passe une enquête de
moralité ?
Bah il le convoque, il lui demande ce
qu'il a à dire, il lui pose tout un tas
de questions sur son environnement
familial et cetera. Il y a une enquête
qui se fait dans le premier cercle,
cercle familial et cetera, une enquête
sur ses antécédents s'il en a. Et donc
ensuite c'est soumis au préfet et
l'enquête, ça se passe comment ? C'est
il se déplace, il ont posé,
c'est lui qui se déplace en général.
Ouais, c'est lui qui est convoqué. Et
puis ensuite, il y a des passages
fichiers, ce qu'on appelle un criblage.
Donc on euh on lui pose la question,
est-ce que dans votre famille, il y a
des gens qui se livrent à des activités
illégales ? Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui est un passif ? Est-ce que vous vous
avez quelque chose à vous reprocher ?
Puis ensuite, il vous dit oui ou non.
Vous pouvez poser quelques questions et
puis vous voyez un petit peu ce qui se
passe. Et donc et donc voilà, il y a une
enquête sur d'environnement en fait qui
est faite ou pas. C'està-dire que si le
bon, il y a des profils dont on sait
très bien qu'il y a pas à fouiller
d'emblé
du genre.
Bon, je sais pas le le le gars qui
arrive de la Creuse qui est issu d'une
famille où dans laquelle tout le monde
est lisse, c'està-dire qu'il y a pas de
d'antécédent judiciaire, il y a
absolument rien. Bon, il y a voilà dans
le contexte actuel, une famille
chrétienne, bon bah forcément ça ça
attire pas la suspicion. Faut dire ce
qu'il y a, faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont. Donc ça passe comme une
lettre à la poste et puis voilà, vous
vous soumettez au préfet, c'est toujours
le préfet qui prend la décision et en
général bon, il y a des gens qui sont
retoqués parfois, d'autres non. parce
que bah quand on vous donne une carte de
police, on vous donne aussi un fling, on
vous donne la possibilité d'accéder au
fichier et naturellement on a des cas
pas que de l'infiltration islamiste.
D'ailleurs, on avait eu par exemple à la
à la DDSP de Bobini des armes qui
avaient disparu. On s'était aperçu que
c'était une une adjointe de sécurité qui
était originaire de la ville de Pentin
qui avait volé ses armes pour les
revendre à des trafiquants de
stupéfiants. Donc bon voilà, ça arrive
ça. Il y a du racisme dans la police
beaucoup. Euh c'est infiltré comme vous
m'avez dit par le Front National, c'est
ça ?
Ah mais très clairement c'est une c'est
c'est moi je l'ai vu, je l'ai constaté,
c'estàdire que je fais l'objet d'une
enquête j'ai fait l'objet d'une enquête
disciplinaire. Je suis convoqué devant
le conseil de discipline.
Très clairement euh
c'est c'està-dire que c'est c'est ce
qu'on appelle une enquête mais pour moi
c'est pas une enquête. C'est un torchon.
Il fait pas bon il fait pas bon de
s'appeler Moulou dans la police.
Oui naturellement. Bah oui, c'est-à-dire
que ou sinon vous devez montrer pas de
blanche et à ce moment-là vous n'êtes
plus vous-même. C'est-à-dire que si vous
effectivement vous avez une force de
caractère, moi c'est mon cas,
c'est-à-dire que j'ai une forte
personnalité, euh bon si vous êtes pas
prêt à baisser le pantalon globalement
ouais vous vous risquez de passer de
mauvais moments. Ouais, très clairement.
C'est ensuite euh
bon, c'est-à-dire que je vais pas dire
que la police est raciste. Je peux pas
dire ça, c'est pas vrai. Parce que vous
voyez euh moi je crache pas dans la
soupe. C'est l'institution qui me fait
vivre, qui m'a qui m'a offert mon
indépendance et cetera. Mais forcément
dans la police, dans une brigade de 15
personnes, vous allez croiser quelques
profils de personnes qui vont peut-être
parfois être un peu décidé à vous créer
des difficultés. Ouais, c'est très
clairement. Et c'est quasi systématique
ça. Ça se matérialise comment ?
Ah bah c'est ça dépend. C'estàd que
c'est quoi ? Ça met des tranches de
jambon dans les vestiaires, des choses
comme ça.
Ouais, on m'a Ouais, on m'a déjà fait le
coup effectivement de la de la tranche
de jambon, moi du tract FN. Vous voyez,
j'ai j'ai écrit une tribune
1 an après le 13 novembre qui que le
point a diffusé. Je l'avais envoyé à
plusieurs médias et le point appelé le
13 novembre vu par un fonctionnaire de
police musulman. C'est une tribune qui a
fait une une audience énorme et donc je
raconte dans cette tribune que bah après
la tent de Charlie, un jour je récupère
ma voiture dans le parking du
commissariat et puis je vois une affiche
de campagne Marine Le Pen sur mon
pare-brise. Donc bon, je voilà, il y
avait une vidéos surveillance donc je
saisis le service de police générale et
mon patron me dit "Ah mince, la vidéo
surveillance fonctionnait pas." Donc
vous voyez, alors que ça aurait été une
affiche Al-Qaïda ou quoi que ce soit, je
pense que la vidéos surveillance aurait
fonctionné ce jour-là, mais là donc du
coup, elle fonctionnait pas.
Et euh
bon bah je vois ça euh je me dis bon euh
c'est voilà c'est c'est un message qui
m'est clairement transmis, c'est-à-dire
que
et donc c'était pas le le et donc quand
je raconte ça dans l'article en
question, mon chef de service à la
police aux frontières donc qui diligent
une enquête contre moi dit "Bah vous
voyez c'est quelqu'un qui s'est mal
intégré chez nous mais dans son article
il raconte qu'il a été il a également
rencontré des difficultés d'intégration
à la DRPP." Bon ben je dis ouais si
effectivement se manger une affiche
c'est avoir une difficulté d'intégration
c'est peut-être sa définition des choses
mais effectivement euh est-ce que on m'a
pas intégrer ? Est-ce qu'on on a refusé
de m'intégrer ou est-ce que c'est moi
qui m'intègre pas ? dans son propos à
lui, c'était moi qui m'intégrait pas.
Mais c'est écoutez, bon, je peux pas
voilà, je là là, j'y peux rien, j'ai pas
de responsabilité dans cette affaire.
Mais
le profil de la le profil typique de la
DRPP, c'est quoi ? C'est c'est Kevin,
c'est Jean-Luc, c'est Charles ?
C'est ce que je vous disais très
clairement. Alors le MRAP avait déjà
saisi avait déjà saisi Michel Aliomarie
à l'époque où elle était ministre de
l'intérieur en 2008 sur cette question
justement des déshabilitations des
retraits d'habilitation secret défense.
Michel Marie avait répondu à son
président qui était molodaonite à
l'époque bah qui avait le mur du secret
défense et que donc il pouvait pas se
justifier de ses retraits. Mais en tout
cas le MRAP avait signalé que ces
retraits étaient particulièrement
suspects puisque ça concernait quasiment
que des jeunes d'origine maghrébine ou
africaine. Et bon par la suite ça a pas
incité la DRPP à changer de politique.
Donc moi, bon, je sais que récemment
quand on a eu une affaire qui concernait
le SDLP, donc l'ancien SPHP, on a eu
j'ai eu une réunion off avec
une personnalité
proche de la République en marche, donc
un homme une personne qui qui était
proche de la présidence de la République
qui avait un contact avec Macron
Castaner qui a réuni un certain nombre
de fonctionnaires qui a fait un appel
sur les médias en disant bah venez. Et
donc je me suis aperçu qu'on était des
dizaines en fait dans ce cas-là. C'estàd
que une personne une une fonctionnaire,
je crois qui a exercé dans les hautes
scènes qui dit "Bah moi, je sais pas, on
a eu un débat, on a parlé de politique
avec des avec des des collègues, je
crois que ça concernait les prières de
rue à Clich Cliché Lagaren. J'étais pas
d'accord avec eux. Bon, ils ont ils ont
commencé à baver et ensuite la direction
a appelé à vous avez 1 heure pour
récupérer vos affaires et quitter le
service." Vous voyez ? Donc du coup bah
enfin c'est c'est un peu compliqué, on
va dire. Voilà. C'est
après
comment réagir face à la situation. Moi
je sais que j'ai des collègues qui sont
encore et qui me disent "Bah écoute, en
attendant je me fais discret, j'arrête
de respirer et puis on peut-être que
c'est une période qui finira par
passer." Bon moi je suis un peu
rancunier, voyez, je suis un peu fier
aussi. Et
vous êtes français ?
Ah français sans complexe, j'ai envie de
dire. Voyez, je demande pas
l'autorisation. C'est ce qui a l'air
d'embêter pas mal de monde d'ailleurs,
mais c'est pas grave. On peut pas plaire
à tout le monde.
Santé, mon ami.
Santé.
Est-ce qu'il y a des problèmes au sein
même des services, au sein des
directions des services du genre on
serre les coudes, on s'arrange ? L'IGPN,
l'IGPN c'est clean, c'est pas clean, ça
ferme les yeux sur certains dossiers.
C'est deux sujets différents. Alors la
solidarité entre policiers, je l'ai déjà
dit dans les médias et je le redis,
c'est quelque chose, c'est un fantasme
en fait. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas
cette culture, elle vous est pas
inculquée. Vous arrivez à l'école,
on vous dit voilà, vous êtes parchambré
de 5 déjà on vous
avez fait quelle école de police ?
Wasel Rouan Wassel.
Wassel
c'est c'est vers Rouan ça ? Non.
Rouan ou Ouais, c'est Saint-Étienne du
Rouvret. Zone à éducation prioritaire
possible. Voilà. Mais c'est c'est
Saint-Étienne du Rouvret. Vous sortez,
vous avez le rond-point des vaches. Vous
sortez de l'école, vous avez ce qu'on
appelle le rond-point des vaches à
Saint-Étien du Rouvret. Et donc
bon, j'arrive et puis naturellement vous
on vous dit bon ben il y a des services,
il y a de tout. Il y a des gens qui vont
se retrouver au milieu du Carrefour à
Paris à faire la circulation et puis
vous avez des gens qui vont aller en
police judiciaire, en police aux
frontières, au renseignement et il y
aura un classement en fin de scolarité.
Tous ceux qui sont autour de vous sont
vos concurrents. Donc vont essayer
d'être loyaux dans la mesure du
possible.
Gardien de la paix, c'est plus proche de
polytechnicien ou de CAP ?
Aujourd'hui, c'est bac, c'est niveau bac
jusqu'à ça c'est arrivé en 2005, il y a
eu une réforme. Avant, c'était il y
avait pas de conditions de diplôme et
aujourd'hui ils ont ils ont quand même
essayé de remonter un petit peu le
niveau. Donc c'est bac mais le niveau
moyen des gens qui se présentent, c'est
bac + 3. Après on a on a quand même des
passerelles, on a les cadets de la
République, on a des adjoints de
sécurité qui passent le concours en
interne et qui se faufilent jusqu'au
concours de gardien de la paix.
Revenons aux écoles de police.
Je vais pas critiquer l'ensemble de mes
collègues. Je pense
c'est du ramassage scolaire, ils
engagent un peu tout le monde ou pas du
tout ? Il y a vraiment un filtre ?
Bah, je sais que sur le dernier
concours, ils ont baissé la moyenne
d'obtention à 8/ 20, je crois, parce que
bah parce qu'il y avait pas assez de
candidats.
Donc bon, après, sachant que le niveau
du bac a ces dernières années a quand
même un petit peu décliné aussi. Donc
après, je dirais qu'après il y a une
sélection naturelle, c'est-à-dire que
vous avez des postes, vous avez des le
marché est ouvert et puis ensuite bah
que les meilleurs gagnent et puis voilà.
Et donc naturellement bah quand les plus
mauvais réussissent pas à gagner, bah il
y a une façon éventuellement de se
faufiler, c'est de vous supplanter, de
vous faire des coupas et cetera. Et donc
du genre
ah bah c'est le le principe même, c'est
la balance. C'est-à-dire que bah pour
être bien vu, il faut se rapprocher des
chefs et donc le rôle de balance que ce
soit dans les brigades ou quoi que ce
soit et que on va dire que ça manque pas
de candidat globalement. Moi c'est ce
dont je me suis aperçu quand j'ai été
affecté à la à la police aux frontières
après la DRPP. Je suis allé voir la
commandante
savez, je lu dit "Écoutez, il y a
quelque chose qui me dérange, c'est
cette sensation justement d'être pied et
que vous soyez informé de tout." Je dis
"Vous savez, c'est bien euh de contrôler
les choses, mais on est quand même dans
un service de police. Les gens sont
majeurs, vaccinés, ils sont armés. Donc,
il faut un moment laisser les gens faire
leur vie et essayer de peut-être
d'éviter d'être tenu au courant de tout
ce qui se dit, tout ce qui se fait. Ça a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt, on a tous
beaucoup de travail. Occupez-vous donc
d'autres choses." Elle l'a reconnu, elle
m'a dit "Oui, oui, c'est vrai, vous avez
raison mais vous comprenez."
Oui, mais naturellement, mais après
c'est difficile d'être solidaire du
reste des collègues quand vous savez
vous repérez assez facilement les deux
ou trois personnes qui euh bon par
exemple, on en avait un Mathieu qui
avait qui était un peu trop stupide pour
par exemple passer euh les les comment
dire les les qui avait pas le niveau
intellectuel si vous voulez pour passer
le le les examens de brigadiers. Donc
bon, globalement, il s'est humilié, il
s'est traîné à terre devant la
hiérarchie en se faisant passer pour un
bad boy devant le reste de la brigade et
à la fin, il a réussi à être nommé au
choix, c'est-à-dire avec l'appui de la
hiérarchie et du syndicat, vous pouvez
être nommé au choix et donc être nommé
brigadier sans passer les examens. Donc
globalement, il y a un peu ça. Bon, ceux
qui sont pas sur la liste euh de
prétendants à l'avancement, ce qu'ils
font, c'est que il y en avait une par
exemple, bon bah c'était pour poser des
vacances, c'est-à-dire que vous posez
vos vacances pour être en famille à
Noël, comme il y a pas assez de place
pour tout le monde, bah si vous voulez
être dans les petits papiers de la
hiérarchie, bon bah vous plantez deux
trois collègues, vous faites la la
pouvve he clairement et vous passez
devant les autres. Moi, j'ai l entre les
lignes si vous voulez. J'ai 43 ans, je
viens du renseignement, je suis quand
même bien avisé de la nature humaine. On
se rend compte que ça se passe comme ça
et donc moi, bon, je discute pas avec
eux. J'ai compris leur petit manège mais
bon, je descends pas à ce niveau. Je
vais voir la hiérarchie, je leur ai dit
"Écoutez, j'ai compris ce qui se
passait. Donc maintenant, si vous voulez
jouer à ça avec moi, vous pouvez." Et
puis à ce moment-là, on se retrouve dans
des tranchées face- à face où si vous
voulez, on peut travailler en bonne
intelligence. Et puis bon,
naturellement, on dit "Oui, oui, vous
inquiétez pas, on va travailler en bonne
intelligence." Bon, après, j'ai raconté
ailleurs ce qu'ils ont essayé de faire
par la suite et naturellement, bon, il y
a eu mes ententes. Voilà.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé par la suite ?
Bah, naturellement, ils ont convoqué une
de mes collègues. Bon, déjà, j'ai
découvert du comment on va dire du
tractage et de l'affichage à caractère
raciste dans dans l'institution. Donc,
je l'ai signalé à l'IGPN directement. Je
l'ai pas signalé à la hiérarchie parce
que ça relève pas de la hiérarchie, ça
relève de l'IGPN. Et donc ça, ça m'a été
reproché. Ils ont convoqué une collègue,
ils ont essayé de me faire accuser de
harcèlement. Donc ils ont essayé de der
avec elle pour la faire muter parce
qu'elle était de province et donc et que
comme elle a eu le bon réflexe de venir
me voir et de m'en parler, je l'ai
rignéalé à l'IGPN. Voilà. Et puis là
depuis ils ont essayé de me broyer hein.
Ils ont ils l'ont broyé elle aussi
d'ailleurs la pauvre. Donc d'ailleurs,
je tiens à remercier les internautes qui
ont contribué à la collecte parce que ça
m'a permis de lui envoyer de quoi
financer ses frais d'avocat. Voilà.
Vous avez une cagnotte.
Oui. Sur le pot commun. Vous mettez
soutien à Noam à noir et puis vous la
trouvez assez facilement.
D'accord. A noir, ça s'écrit
A N O U A R. Donc soutien au lanceur
d'alerte, vous tapez Noam Nam à noir sur
le pot commun et vous la trouvez. Donc
j'ai fait une relance hier sur les
réseaux sociaux. Bon, il y a eu
énormément de relais et cetera, mais on
n pas réussi à recateurs. J'en ai eu un
en 24 heures, donc voilà qui
il aura peut-être plusieurs après.
On espère. On touche du monde.
Le suicide dans la police.
Bah écoutez, oui, c'est bah c'est un peu
le résultat de tout ce que je dénonce
avec Vigie depuis depuis plusieurs
semaines. Ça fait
Vigie syndicat
fait. Oui, c'est
quand Castaner vous dit que Vigie c'est
pas un syndicat,
c'est un syndicat. On est reconnu
légalement comme tel. Après vous voyez,
monsieur Castaner dit aussi que Éric
Drouet et Jérôme pardon et Maxime Nicole
sont responsables civilement de
l'incendie du Fouquet et qu'ils vont
devoir payer. Donc je pense qu'il a mal
compris le système de je principe de
séparation des pouvoirs et peut-être le
système législatif français. Et donc
bon, quand il dit que vigie est pas un
syndicat, c'est à peu près du même
ordre. On est un syndicat, on est ultra
minoritaire.
On représente exactement 574
fonctionnaires. Comme ça c'est dit quand
les gens disent 0,4 %. Effectivement, on
a 150000 fonctionnaires de police,
fonctionnaires pas forcément de police
mais administratifs et cetera dans au
ministère de l'intérieur. Et nous on
représente uniquement des fonctionnaires
de police et on en représente 574. Donc
voilà. Après si dans le grand débat
monsieur Macron s'avisait de dire au
maire d'un village de 600 habitants non
mais vous je vous écoute pas je vous
reçois pas vous représentez personne et
ça serait quand même mal reçu. Donc bah
c'est exactement les propos qui ont été
tenus par le ministre de l'intérieur à
notre rencontre alors que bon
proportionnellement je dirais par
rapport à la population française on
serait plutôt une ville de 100000
habitants. Je dis ça au hasard, j'ai pas
calculé mais bon voilà, il a estimé que
nos positionosition méritait de ne
méritait pas en tout cas d'être prise en
compte alors qu'on a si vous surveiller
les réseaux sociaux, on a quand même
souvent raison depuis le début de ce
conflit mais on n pas malheureusement
on n pas trouvé de terrain d'entente
avec le ministère de l'intérieur. Voilà.
Le suicide des fonctionnaires avec leur
hommes de service, c'est un appel à
l'aide ? C'est un geste fort ? C'est
bah c'est un renoncement à la vise là.
C'est plus un appel à l'aide.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a des personnes qui
se retrouvent laminées par le système.
Moi, je vous savez, je je suis
actuellement dans le congé long maladie.
Donc, je je vais on m'impose des
convocations chez le médecin
divisionnaire et notamment le
psychiatre. Et quand je suis allé le
voir, il m'a dit "Me racontez pas ce qui
s'est passé, j'ai vu votre tronche" et
j'ai tout de suite compris, voyez. Donc
bon voilà, ça ça vous donne un ordre
d'idée. Et euh donc il me dit "Faites
attention, vous avez des enfants, vous
avez quand même une carrière à mener."
Et il me dit "Vous savez moi ça fait des
années que je travaille pour la police
que je reçois des fonctionnaires et
c'est une machine à broyer les hommes."
Il me dit clairement quand ils vous ont
dans le collimateur, il vous explose
dans tous les sens. Et c'est toujours le
même procédé. C'est-à-dire que moi je me
souviens quand je suis arrivé à l'école,
j'étais j'avais j'étais père d'un
enfant. Ça j'avais ma fille qui était
bébé.
Je sais quand je faisais les tours de
stade, je crachais mes poumons et
j'avais sa photo, ça m'aidait à courir
si vous voulez. C'était un peu ma
motivation. Il y avait des jeunes
collègues qui avait eu la pêche et
cetera mais qui avaient pas forcément
les mêmes motivations. Et donc je me
souviens, il y en a un, il s'est acheté
une voiture tout de suite on touchait
1300 € en tant qu'élève gardien de
l'appel. Lui 15000 € il a pris un
crédit, une voiture parce que bon, vous
voyez, il avait 18 ou 19 ans, il y avait
les nanas et cetera. Donc lui son truc
c'était la voiture. Et un jour le
formateur l'a convoqué, lui a dit
"Écoute, tu es pas assez bon à l'école,
tu comprends ? On va peut-être te virer
là. Les larmes ont coulé directement.
C'était un robinet. C'était à carchè
haute pression parce que le mec s'est
dit "Merde, je me suis endetté, j'ai
pris une voiture et cetera. Je je" le
mec s'est projeté, il s'est dit "Dans 2
semaines, j'achète un appart" et d'un
coup, on lui explique que tout peut
s'arrêter.
Et donc un fonctionnaire de police qui
est père de famille, une mère de famille
qui a 10 ans d'expérience, qui est
endetté, il lui reste 20 ans de traite à
payer. On l'a convoqué à l'UGPN, on lui
dit "Ou là là, on nous a dit des choses
sur vous, c'est pas très bien, vous
comprenez ? Il va falloir être sympa
sinon ça va s'arrêter. Bon ben là, il y
en a malheureusement qui euh où il y en
a certains à qui on lui dit pas à qui on
dit pas il faudrait être sympa. Il y en
a certains à qui on dit bah écoute on
t'aime pas et tu vas dégager. Il a
certains malheureusement qui bah qui
trouvent pas les ressources nécessaires
pour continuer à se battre et à vivre et
qui se flinguent. Mais quand on nous dit
c'est des problématiques personnelles,
je suis désolé mais on n pas 80 suicides
annuels chez les plombiers quoi. Donc on
se rend bien compte qu'il y a un lien il
y a un rapport de cause à effet que
parfois le ministère de l'intérieur
essaie de nier. Donc bon après chacun se
fait sa propre opinion sur les choses
mais naturellement chez VII en tout cas
on estime que le rapport est est avéré.
Voilà.
D'ailleurs, j'en profite pour dire que
du temps de Manuel Vals au ministère de
l'intérieur, justement, on avait eu
quelques idées assez intéressante où on
avait parlé de régionaliser le concours.
C'est-à-dire que bon, un fonctionnaire
qui est toulousain, marseillais, quand
il travaille quand début de sa carrière
apparaît, on lui dit "Bah écoute,
Marseille oublie ou sinon tu peux y
repenser, mais dans 10 à 15 ans,
peut-être 20 ans." Et à un moment, on
s'est dit "Bah ça sert à rien de
torturer les gens par plaisir. Bah, un
gars qui passe son concours à Besançon
bah pourquoi est-ce qu'il travaillerait
pas à Besançon ?" on peut régionaliser
le concours, il y aura peut-être moins
de place mais au moins le et c'est une
idée bah qui avait germé qui a été
complètement abandonné. Donc je la
remets aujourd'hui un petit peu sur la
table en disant bah pourquoi est-ce
qu'on on a ce malin plaisir à torturer
des fonctionnaires qui commencent.
C'est-à-dire que un gars est plein
d'énergie, plein d'espoir, plein de
conviction. Vous arrivez, il veut être
policier éventuellement chez lui. Bon,
s'il est pas assez bon pour être bien
classé, retourner chez lui au départ ou
s'il y a pas de poste tout simplement,
dit "OK, tu vas aller là. Mais au début,
c'est la salle de commandement. C'estàd
il va passer 3 ans au téléphone à
recevoir les appels 17. Il va rester à
l'accueil du commissariat. Il va rester
en garde statique devant un ministère ou
devant une ambassade. Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait ça ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on on
d'office on on part du principe qu'il
faut manger son pain noir et qu'il faut
tuer la motivation des jeunes recrues.
Quel plaisir Sadic on éprouve à à faire
ce genre de chos. Moi je l'ai vécu hein.
Mon premier poste, c'était un poste de
garde où on m'a mis au portique et puis
il fallait fouiller les sacs à mains au
portique et cetera aux U et puis à un
moment vous passez des journées de 10h
comme ça et puis vous en avez marre et
vous dites "Merde, j'ai pas choisi le
bon taf."
éventuellement vous prenez votre mal en
patience mais pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'on on met pas ces gens je dirais sous
tutelle peut-être de personnes gradé
puis on pourquoi est-ce qu'on les laisse
pas exercer le métier qu'elles aiment
tout simplement
parce qu'un ordonné doit être exécuté
sans être discuté il faut bien
la police je crois que c'est pas l'armée
on a ce cette forme de complexe par
rapport à l'armée mais la police c'est
pas une institution militaire les gens
ont quand même le droit d'être heureux
dans leur métier voyez quand vous
arrivez
et les gens sont heureux à l'armée hein
sans doute plus qu'en police je pense
parce qu'on est moins concerné par par
le suicide, même si ça existe puisque on
a eu un suicide lundi dernier d'une
d'une militaire originaire de
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui était présente à
Roissi pour une opération sentinelle et
qui s'est suicidé dans sa chambre paix à
son âme et condoléance à sa famille.
Bon, Castaner, c'est un bon ministre,
c'est pas un bon ministre, il gère bien
la sûreté de l'État, la sécurité
publique.
Bah écoutez, c'est un bon ministre ou
pas, j'en sais rien. Je suis pas
président de la République, je suis pas
premier ministre. On va rester modeste.
Après ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'est certainement pas un technicien de
la sécurité. Bon je pense que l'homme de
l'ombre c'est Laurent Nunz hein très
clairement qui reste assez souvent
silencieux. Donc je pense que les rôles
sont bien répartis. C'est-à-dire que
monsieur
un qui va en boîte de nuit, l'autre qui
fait le boulot.
Bah écoutez
il y en a un qui joue au poker et
l'autre qui fait le boulot. C'est ça.
Je me permettrai pas ce genre de
d'illustration mais en tout cas
clairement
en tout cas je sauf mes méprises de ma
part mais je pense que en fait on est
plus dans la stratégie politique
qu'autre chose. C'estàd que si vous
analysez la situation des 15 dernières
années, à chaque fois qu'on a positionné
un jeune loup au poste de ministre de
l'intérieur, c'était imprésidentiable
par la suite. Donc je pense qu'Emmanuel
Macron a bien compris qui qui devait
positionner ou pas à ce poste. qu'on a
eu Gérard Colomb qui a priori n'était
pas partant pour la présidentielle de
2022 dans un premier temps. qui s'est
retiré et ensuite ça a été quand même je
pense un une énigme assez difficile à
résoudre pour la majorité savoir qui on
pouvait placer au poste à ce poste et a
priori c'était il était pas envisageable
de placer quelqu'un d'autre
que que monsieur Cass qui était quand
même un fidèle lieutenant de d'Emmanuel
Macron mais par contre il avait pas la
technicité nécessaire donc il lui a été
adjoint un un un haut fonctionnaire qui
a choisi de franchir le pas de s'ériger
en en secrétaire d'état Et le tandème
euh sur le papier avait l'air de de bien
fonctionner,
mais euh naturellement en pratique avec
la crise des gilets jaunes, ce qu'on a
appelé la purge aussi he qui a était une
crise de banlieu euh
en 2008. Non
non, la purge c'était juste à la
nomination là en novembre dernier après
le jour d'Halloween en octobre, le 29
octobre.
Ah le le canular,
c'était pas un canular, ça a été suivi
de fait quand même hein. Donc
quel type de fait ?
En banlieu des voitures incendies et
cetera. Ça a été ça a pas été suivi
comme ça aurait pu l'être mais en tout
cas
la purge c'était il fallait se faire un
flic pendant la nuit ou un truc comme
ça. Oui, voilà, il y avait un appel au
meurtre et cetera, donc à l'émeut en
tout cas à l'insurrection des banlieux
et donc ça a pas été bon les attentat
Strasbourg et cetera donc ça pas été une
masse à faire à gérer
et il y a une réactivité
qui a quand même été
bon qui a été ce qu'elle a été quoi mais
du point de vue de la gestion des des
dispositifs de sécurité l'affaire Benala
et cetera, je pense que le bilan
aujourd'hui est plutôt un bilan
catastrophique. J'en suis assez triste
pour Laurent Nunes qui est quelqu'un que
j'estime beaucoup mais il a fait le
choix de bon les partis au début sa
carrière étaient contrôleur des impôts.
aujourd'hui les secrétaires d'état donc
je pense qu'il a fait un bon choix de
carrière mais effectivement
j'ai envie de dire que bon le bilan
étant ce qu'il est je pense que je sais
on tout le monde s'est posé la question
de savoir si on pouvait faire pire que
François Hollande
en terme de de bilan présidentiel et je
crois que là aujourd'hui on en est pas
loin ou sinon je peut-être que le CAP
est franchi.
Comment vous expliquez qu'il y a pas eu
un attentat terroriste sur les gilets
jaunes ? Je pense que les islamistes
sont pas forcément les imbéciles qu'on
croit. C'est des gars qui se baladent à
d'autres chameaux avec des babouches et
des jabas. Je pense qu'ils observent la
situation politique et ils se rendent
bien compte qu'un attentat terroriste
aujourd'hui, ça pourrait fédérer la
population française contre l'islamiste.
D'ailleurs, sans même là sans même qu'il
y ait d'attentat, bon il y en a eu,
c'est ça reste des attentats, on va
dire, c'est pas des attentats de grande
ampleur, mais il y en a eu quelques-uns.
Mais on se rend bien compte que le le
système médiatique et politique essaie
de fédérer les Français contre les
musulmans. On a eu l'affaire du hijab de
Décathlon, on a eu cette jeune fille
voilée qui a postulé à vous voyez ça ça
devient des affaires d'état alors que
c'est des trucs complètement ridicule au
départ.
Pour contre la Bourka ?
Moi je suis contre, c'est interdit par
la loi donc naturellement je suis
contre. Ça sans réserve mais
cette femme est volée.
Ah non pas du tout. Non non non non non.
Mes filles, j'ai je suis papa de deux
filles également et on dire je
respecterai toujours leur liberté. Je
peux pas les les mais en tout cas moi je
non je pense que le voile aujourd'hui en
France c'est la mort sociale. Très
clairement le nicab n'en parlons même
pas c'est c'est le c'est c'est être hors
la loi et c'est une situation de mort
sociale avérée. Donc non non c'est moi
savez on m'a inculqué le respect de la
France de ses valeurs et je prends pas
la liberté comme justement une une
l'autorisation de d'offenser si vous
voulez. Donc la France est un pays
multimillénaire, une culture
multimillénaire. Et quand mes parents
sont arrivés, ils sont arrivés, c'était
l'exil économique mais aussi l'exil
politique. Et quelque part euh donc
moi je suis pas arrivé, je suis né en
France mais on n'est pas arrivé en
terrain conquis. On a bien compris qu'il
y avait des codes et que d'ailleurs je
vois pas l'intérêt aujourd'hui d'aller
agresser je dirais euh le l'opinion
publique en se baladant Laba ou quoi que
ce soit quoi. Je je si vous voulez je
quand quand j'ai fait l'interview pour
le média, il y a eu j'ai eu énormément
de messages d'encouragement de la part
de francofançais, c'est de français de
sou si je peux le me permettre mais
également de français d'origine
africaine maghrébine et j'ai eu des
messages extrêmement agressifs aussi que
j'ai j'ai publié sur Twitter de gens qui
disaient pour qui bizarrement il y avait
des termes qui ét employés traître donc
un français d'origine maghrine qui
s'engage pour la France pour la police
française c'est un traître que je vais
pas dire que j'aurais aimé débattre avec
ces personnes, elle m'intéresse pas
parce que le niveau est trop bas quand
même assez inquiétant qu'il y a des
personnes aujourd'hui qui vivent en
France qui parlent français qui écrivent
français et qui considèrent que
s'engager pour la France aujourd'hui est
un acte de traîtrise. Donc je pense que
la France de toute façon devra tôt ou
tard s'occuper de ce problème.
C'est-à-dire
comment
ben je dirais pour tout le monde.
à un moment j'avais proposé pour ce qui
est ce qui était des personnes
condamnées pour dans le cadre de d'actes
terroristes la déchéance de nationalité
mais je pense qu'à un moment il va aussi
peut-être falloir condamner à une forme
de mort sociale ce type de personne
c'est-à-dire les identifier les faire
condamner parce que l'outrage au drapeau
français ou à la nation aujourd'hui est
condamné prévu et condamné par la loi
que ça figure dans le casier judiciaire
et que ces personnes ne puissent pas
prétendre à des fonctions que ce soit
dans les grandes entreprises ou dans
l'administration française. dire "OK, tu
détestes la France, il y a pas de souci
mais par contre la France veut pas de
toi aujourd'hui même si tu es français
de fait voilà on te rejette et je crois
que ce serait pas un acte de
discrimination que de procéder ainsi."
Un gars vous dit "La tenue de référence
pour moi c'est laadaba,
c'est le voile islamique, c'est les
babouches, voilà et la liberté me
l'autorise. Donc je vous emmerde tous et
nique la France." Bon ben un mec qui
vous dit ça, on a envie de lui dire
"Barre-toi au Yémen." Le gars vous dit
"Non, je reste là parce que j'ai le
droit. OK, tu vas rester là." Mais nous
aussi, on a le droit de pas t'aimer et
on va te le faire savoir. Voilà, tout
simplement
la Vous voyez comment la sûreté du
renseignement français, la capacité du
renseignement en français à s'endurcir.
Vous voyez comment les quelles sont vos
préconisations pour le le renseignement
en français ?
Bah déjà qu'on arrête de changer tous
les 2 ans parce que vous savez à un
moment vous aviez eu la fusion la ce
qu'on avait appelé la fusion qui était
tout sauf une fusion en fait entre DST
et Oui, voilà. par SarkoZi, il y a eu un
petit peu un écrémage.
Oui. Bon, on va on va dire qu'il a voulu
créer un FBI à la française. Donc, on a
eu la destruction des archives un moment
inopportun parce que naturellement quand
vous faites disparaître une une
direction, bah il faut il faut la
législation en tout cas de l'ACNIL
impose la destruction des archives. Donc
c'était pas forcément le moment le plus
opportun. Ensuite, on a eu l'asdige,
donc la sous-direction de l'information
générale qui est une sous-direction de
de qui était une sous-direction de la
sécurité publique qui était censé
remplacer les RG. Ensuite, bon, j'en ai
fait partie dans le 93, on a été dessisi
au profil de la DRPP, donc on a
redécoupé les territoires dans le cadre
du Grand Paris. On s'est dit "Ah ben
non, finalement même Roissie d'ailleurs,
on on a démantelé le renseignement sur
la petite couronne et sur Roissie et on
l'a rattaché à la DRPP. Donc il a fallu
recréer une base de données parce qu'on
a encore une fois détruit les archives.
Ensuite, quand il y a eu la Fermera,
plus personne voulait être le boss de la
DCRI puisqu'il y avait eu un échec
cuisant. Donc, on a créé la DGSI qui
devait être à la base sous tutelle du
Premier ministre et qui devait fédérer
la communauté du renseignement. Ça s'est
jamais fait puisque jusqu'à preuve du
contraire, la DGSI est toujours sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur.
Ensuite, on a eu la DPSD qui a été
démantelée, qui est devenue la DRSD au
niveau du du ministère de la défense.
Vous voyez ? Et puis d'ailleurs, la
Commission nationale de contrôle des des
interceptions de sécurité est devenue la
CNCR, contrôle national, commission
nationale de contrôle du renseignement.
Donc ça ça arrête pas de changer. Je
maîtrise plus du tout le mon ancien
service qui s'appelait le STR93 est
devenu le SRT. Ils ont fait des
réunions, ils sont dit "Ah non, service
territorial de renseignement c'est pas
bon. On va appeler ça service de
renseignement territorial." Vous voyez ?
Bon, à un moment vous dites "Bon les
gars,
voilà, c'est en attendant les bon les
terroristes se sont bah eux, ils ont pas
attendu si vous voulez la réforme du
renseignement ou quoi que ce soit. Ils
font ce qu'ils ont à faire et ils
foncent quoi ?" C'est
c'est quoi ? C'est question internet.
C'est quoi votre définition du
terrorisme ?
Alors euh
la la définition euh elle a évolué ces
dernières années. Bon, la mienne, elle
est pas très intéressante, mais la le
terrorisme, si vous voulez, c'était au
tout départ euh un acte de tuerie de
masse euh qui générerait un nombre de
victimes importants euh et qui
comporterait une dimension de
revendication politique. Voilà, c'était
un petit peu donc il fallait qu'il y ait
un nombre important de victimes, une
revendication politique et une diffusion
importante du point de vue de la
communication justement de de cet acte.
La guerre en Irak, c'est du terrorisme.
La guerre en Irak, c'est-à-dire qui
bouge qui dit "On va les sauver les
petites filles, on va apporter la
démocratie".
Oh, j'en sais rien. Moi, je suis pas
spécialiste de de politique
internationale et encore moins en
matière de géopolitique. Mais
effectivement, bon,
certains parlaient de terrorisme d'État
peut-être ou pas. En tout cas, ça a été
une erreur. Certainement. C'est
Est-ce que vous pensez que la politique
étrangère française et génère du
terrorisme ?
En tout cas, pour ce qui est du
terrorisme qui nous a frappé, je pense
pas parce que la France à l'époque
s'était opposée à l'invasion de l'Irak.
Donc quelque part, on a été les victimes
de de la politique guerrière de de
l'administration Bouche,
de nos alliances.
À l'époque, on était pas allié, bien au
contraire. Bon, après, par la suite, il
y a eu des compromissions qui qui se
sont faites. En tout cas, là, pour le
coup, les français, on a on a rien à
voir dans la destruction de l'Irak.
Après bon à l'époque de monsieur
Sarkozi, on s'est aventura en Libye, on
n' pas été forcément ciblé par par le
terrorisme libien.
On n pas on a pas vraiment subi les
conséquences mais ça a été un désastre
effectivement. Ça a été démantelé des
États bon qui étaient ce qu'ils étaient.
C'est des dictatures laïques,
communistes,
parce que le parti basse iraakien et
syrien sont d'inspiration euh
communiste, hein, euh au profit
justement de théologie islamistes qui
ont persécuté les chrétiens d'Orient,
qui ont massacré les minorités et
cetera. Ça a été une erreur. On peut pas
dire le contraire aujourd'hui.
Maintenant, si vous voulez, moi dans ma
position, bah mon boulot c'est de
quadrier le territoire français, de
déterminer le niveau des menaces. Ça l'
plus aujourd'hui. C'est plus mon boulot,
c'est le boulot d'autres personnes.
Est-ce que quand vous travaillez dans
dans ce type d'activité, est-ce que les
pour vous les flux migratoires
représente une porte d'entrée, un risque
?
Bah, je peux pas vous dire le contraire
parce que si vous prenez l'attentat du
13 novembre, on avait quand même deux de
deux terroristes, deux kamikazes, c'est
d'ailleurs les deux premiers du stade de
France qui ont qui étaient des réfugiés
iraakiens munis de faux passeports
syriens. Donc, on peut pas dire que ça
n'existe pas. Mais je sais qu'à un
moment on avait la ce qu'on appelle le
dispositif Frontex, bon qui était un
dispositif de coopération internationale
qui visait justement à contrôler
les entrées de les afflux de migrants
aux portes de l'espace Schengen. Bon ça
ça c'est quelque chose aussi qui a été
démantelé faute de moyens à un moment et
bon c'est c'était quand même pas mal de
au moins de pouvoir identifier
signaliser justement toutes les arrivées
quand on a eu ce genre par exemple
d'événement bah on pouvait savoir à quel
moment et par où les personnes étaient
arrivées. Là, c'était quand même un
petit peu plus difficile.
Autre question internet.
Y a-t-il un avenir dans la police quand
on est musulman
aujourd'hui ? Pour ce qui est des
services spécialisés, je ne le pense
pas. À moins d'être si vous voulez, on
aura toujours besoin de caution. Donc,
il y a toujours quelques quelques
Maghrébains qui vont persister, qui vont
se maintenir dans les services de
renseignement moyennant compromission.
Sa
ce qu' disit, c'était pasfeu qui disait
un truc là-dessus ? Là,
je sais pas. Oui, que c'est quand il y
en a quand il y en a un, ça va. C'est
quand il y en a beaucoup qui a des
problèmes. Mais
est-ce que lui c'est un bon arabe et
l'autre c'est un mauvais arabe ? Non,
c'est pas lui qui dis il avait il avait
tenu en fait il on lui avait présenté un
militant, je crois que c'était en
Auverne et il avait dit effectivement
euh il y a pas de problème, c'est quand
il y en a un ça va encore, c'est quand
il y en a beaucoup qui a des problèmes.
Et il avait été condamné justement par
le MRAP en première instance. En tout
cas, il avait été condamné en première
instance et je crois relaxé en appel
pour ses propos. Donc je pense que c'est
pas une question de nombre. Je crois que
c'est
bon. Je crois qu'aujourd'hui très
clairement euh
si vous voulez c'est c'était un peu une
caricature de la police quand vous étiez
arabe, vous parliez arabe pas plus tard
qu'hier. J'ai reçu un appel d'un d'un
jeune policier qui sortait d'école et
qui m'a dit "Ah, je vous ai vu dans les
médias, j'aimerais faire comme vous,
qu'est-ce que vous me conseillez ?" et
cetera. Je l'ai motivé. Moi, je je veux
pas être, voyez, propager des ondes
négatives en disant "Mais non et cetera,
faut pas être amè." Je dis "Bah vas-y,
fonce, fais ta carrière et cetera." Mais
je dis par contre pense pas que le fait
d'être d'origine maghrébine ou de de
baragouiner un petit peu le langage, le
dialect maghrébin va te permettre comme
ça d'entrer par la grande porte dans les
service de renseignement. C'est pas ce
qui est demandé. Et donc je lui expliqué
un petit peu les objectifs et puis je
lui je bon je lui ai demandé de de faire
preuve d'un peu de modestie, c'estàdire
de faire son boulot de de gardien de la
paix stagiaire, de prendre connaissance
de l'environnement, du territoire et
ensuite d'aller proposer ses services à
la à la première occasion. Voilà. Mais
après à terme si vous voulez euh il faut
faire tomber les tabous. C'est-à-dire
que moi, je suis pas contre le fait
qu'on se serve de moi, mais par contre
il faut que ce soit dit très clairement.
Vous voyez c'est il faut pas endoctriner
les gens en leur disant "Mais vous êtes
français, vous êtes patriote, vous êtes
policier, vous faites partie d'une
institution qui est noble et qu'on vous
utilise à votre insu et on vous jette
comme une vieille chaussette." C'est pas
l'objectif. À la limite si demain on me
dit bah on a besoin de traducteur parce
que voilà on a personne on a besoin de c
ou de ça d'ailleurs je vous avez vu, je
suis pas un très bon traducteur, je
savais pas comment on disait plongeur en
dialecte oriental.
Oui parce que c'est pas votre langue ça
l'égyptien l'arabe littéraire.
Non c'est une langue d'adoption mais
dans laquelle je me débrouille pas mal
si vous voulez. Je
Si c'est une langue d'adoption c'est
parce que vous avez fait de l'urance sur
le
on avait on avait un petit peu des des
personnes de communauté égyptienne. On
avait des diplomates parfois aussi de
par j'ai j'ai rencontré l'imam Tamimi
qui était l'imam de Jérusalem. J'ai
rencontré le le également le
le le curé de Gaza également. Vous voyez
Emmanuel Moussalam qui est donc j'ai
rencontré pas mal de monde. Donc parfois
le fait de pouvoir échanger ne serait-ce
que des politesses en dialecte
moyen-oriental, ça crée une forme de
c'est pas de l'instrumentalisation hein,
mais ça crée une forme de sympathie
naturelle. Après avec les les monarchies
du golf, une fois on m'a présenté un
ambassadeur. Bon, je vais pas citer le
pays, mais d'une, on va dire, d'une
d'une pétromarchie du golf et les gens
qui représentent bien le droit des
femmes, c'est ça ?
Oui, entre autres. Bon, en tout cas qui
essayait au moment des printemps arabes
de renvoyer une image de modernisme et
cetera et une personne me présente
intermédiaire en disant bah voyez
monsieur Noamir du ce qu'il s'appelle le
ministère, il me présente et moi je lui
disfan
honoré. Le mec me regarde avec un air
méprisant et il se barre. Donc en fait
après j'enri avec un ami, je dis mais
pourquoi il s'est comporté comme ça ? Il
dit parce que tu as parlé en arabe, tu
as le mat pour lui ça suffit. pour lui
tu un larbin ça l'intéresse pas il dit
ne jamais faire ça avec les
pétromarchies faut parler français
anglais
parce que c'est les sémites c'est ça
non parce qu'en fait pour eux si vous
voulez on est un peu les romes de les
les maghrébains sont un peu les romes de
de du monde arabe si vous voulez donc
globalement il se dit ah bah si c'est un
arabe il doit pas être vraiment
important voilà donc il s'est barré
parce qu'il s'est dit bah naturellement
ils sont un peu complexés par vous savez
par par leur au-delà de leur statut de
leur richesses c'est des personnes qui
qui qui ont quand même une forme de
complexe d'infériorité donc il préfèrent
les blondes aux yeux bleus. Puis là, ils
s'humilient, ils sourit, ils font ils
sont miux mais pas moi là vous le mec
m'a complètement méprisé. pour ça moi ça
m'a pas dérangé c'est ça c'est c'est
c'est toutes les situations sont bonnes
à pour entre guillemets je dirais
tailler sa pierre à prendre la vie en
quelque sorte voilà
c'est polir sa pierre
voilà
et autre question d'internet que
pensez-vous de Camel Daudi Daudi plus
vieille assignée à résidence de France
écoutez oui je je connais ce dossier pas
au plan judiciaire j'ai pas du tout
travaillé sur ce dossierlà mais je le
vois un peu dans les médias et j'ai
envie de lui demander ce qu'il espère.
C'estd qu'il est résident algérien, il
est pas français. À un moment, on lui a
proposé de repartir en Algérie. Bon,
là-bas, je pense que je crois qu'il fait
l'objet d'une condamnation là-bas, ce
qui l'empêche un peu de repartir. Et il
vit en fait dans une prison assez
louvert en France. Donc moi, je pense
qu' il aurait tout intérêt peut-être à
envisager un départ vers l'Algérie,
peut-être à négocier une forme
d'amnistie ou de d'être défendu, en tout
cas d'engager des démarches pour pouvoir
jouir de sa liberté en Algérie. Mais
vous voyez, c'est c'est assez
symptomatique. C'est-à-dire qu'au centre
de rétention, j'avais aussi un certain
nombre de de de de résidents algériens
qui bon je me souviens d'une personne
qui avait avalé des lames de rasoir pour
pas le jour de son expulsion pour
justement éviter l'expulsion.
et euh de bon on avait un certain nombre
de cas comme ça de de personnes qui
Chamami le chanteur qui avait préféré je
sais qu'il était exilé en Algérie à un
moment dans l'attente de son procès,
Boutfica lui avait donné des garanties
en lui disant voilà nous on t'extradra
pas a priori c'est des informations qui
circulaient en off et il a préféré se
rendre en France purger une peine de
prison être jugé en assise. D'ailleurs,
il avait été jugé à Bobini et copé de 5
ans de prison hein. Donc c'est sa
carrière est complètement foutue
aujourd'hui. après ce qui s'est passé à
priori en tout cas et mais mais voilà,
jouir d'une liberté en France même après
une condamnation, après une une
réputation et cetera, moment voyez ça ça
laisse penser que finalement qu'est-ce
la prison en France est meilleure que la
liberté en Algérie. C'est c'est triste
quand même ce qui est renvoyé en terme
d'image. Vous voyez, c'est donc moi je
je leur pose la question de savoir bah
est-ce que c'est vrai ? Est-ce que
vraiment la rétention la détention en
France est préférable à la liberté en
Algérie ? à ce moment-là, arrêtez de
dire ce que vous dites aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire de dire que les gens qui
servent la France sont des traîtres, des
archis et cetera. Eux l'ont pas dit
hein, les personnes nominamment cité
mais dans les dans la la bouche des
jeunes de banlou, c'est ce que vous
entendez. One two fre vive l'Algérie.
Chaque fois qu'il y a un match de foot,
vous voyez, moi je je n'énigre pas du
tout l'Algérie, hein. Bien au contraire,
j'ai de la famille qui vit. Euh mais euh
honnêtement euh donc à un moment, faut
aussi raison garder et peut-être revenir
à des fondamentaux, se dire bah c'est
pas compatible, on peut pas dire que
l'Algérie top. meilleur pays du monde
qu'on peut pas critiquer et cetera et
puis avoir cette attitude. Voyez
donc l'avenir du renseignement français
çaen est où ? Les préconisation ?
Bah disons que j'avais un chef de
service qui me disait deux choses
concernant justement l'évolution de de
car disait entre l'opportuniste
et le professionnel, celui qu'on
retrouve 30 ans après, c'est toujours le
professionnel. L'opportuniste finit
toujours par disparaître. Peut-être
qu'il faudrait arrêter justement de
distribuer les postes comme ça au gré de
des des changements politiques
dans un premier temps. Et un autre chef
de service me disait qu'il avait visité
des pays scandinaves et que là-bas le
ministère de la justice et le ministère
de l'intérieur étaient regroupé.
C'est-à-dire que sous le sous une
autorité unique, c'est l'équivalence qui
serait un garde des sauts et un
procureur de la République. Et
finalement, il le procureur avait à la
fois le rôle d'assermenter, de
diligenter les procédures, le rôle qu'il
a en France, mais il avait également le
rôle de manager les effectifs de police.
Et donc quelque part, il y avait aussi
le même principe de séparation des
pouvoirs, mais que la police était sous
l'autorité de la justice de façon plus
explicite, on va dire, et que ça
fonctionnait a priori un peu mieux que
qu'en France. Donc
moi, je suis pas partisan, pourtant
c'est le le le fonctionnaire du
renseignement, l'ancien fonctionnaire du
renseignement qui vous dit, mais des
mesures administratives. Vous voyez en
ce moment, on a un débat sur le fichier
des interdits de manifestation et
cetera. Moi, je comprends pas cette
obsession. qu'on a depuis quelques mois,
ça avait été le cas pour la loi Colomb
justement de de vouloir échapper aux
dispositions des procureurs et des
magistrats, c'est de de laisser les
préfets en toute autonomie prendre des
mesures à l'encontre de personnes, c'est
des mesures de restriction de liberté
sans passer par la justice. Voyez, on
parlait par exemple pour la loi
cette loi, cette fameuse loi qui
concerne les manifestants. vous dit
"Oui, mais ça va être super parce que
les les frais faits vont pouvoir décider
justement de de mesures qui vont
permettre de de pouvoir contrôler les
sacs des gens avec leur rassentiment."
Mais ça ça existe déjà. Moi, si
j'appelle demain, je suis chef d'un
dispositif d'ordre public, j'appelle le
parquet, je dis "Écoutez, on a un risque
pour samedi sur une manifestation.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous formuler une
réquisition pour contrôler les sacs des
usagers à l'entrée des Champs-Élysées ?
Jamais le procureur de la République va
vous refuser la réquisition. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on veut se passer
du partenariat justement des magistrats
pour pouvoir agir en autonomie ? bah
parce que les préfets sont sous
l'autorité peut-être du ministre de
l'intérieur qui sont nommés par le
ministre de l'intérieur. Donc on veut
tout contrôler. Et moi j'ai pas cette
obsession à titre personnel peut-être
parce que je suis pas gradé mais j'ai
pas cette cette obsession du pouvoir de
vouloir contrôler les choses, décider de
tout en toute autonomie.
C'est c'est là on s'éloigne de cette
vision justement du service public
de la sécurité de nos concitoyens. Là
euh vous voyez c'est des c'est des gens
qui se regardent un peu dans le nombril
et je suis pas partisan de ce type de
procédé mais malheureusement les lois
sont votées et euh bon bah après il y a
une dimension irréversible hein dans
dans l'adoption de ces textes.
Le ramassage scolaire qui est effectué
par la surveillance de masse, vous y
croyez ? Vous y croyez pas pour gérer
les questions de terrorisme ?
C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que vous appelez
le
l'interception de masse ?
Je crois que en fait
renseignement au détriment du
renseignement humain,
je crois qu'on a une culture de la
réactivité, vous savez, de la
communication. D'ailleurs, c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure quand vous
me parliez de ministre de l'intérieur.
C'est que bon, quand on a des attentats,
bah il faut réagir, il faut fermer cin
ou six mosquées, il faut il faut
assigner des gens à résidence, il faut
interpeller des personnes dans les
filières et puis les faire comparaître
devant la justice parce que le peuple
réclame justice, réclame vengeance et
donc on va on va on va on va réchauffer
des vieux dossiers et cetera mais et ça
masque finalement notre efficacité et
l'identitude. Peut-être qu'on eu
certains services à prévenir justement
ces agissements.
Après euh bon forcément il y a des
dommages collatérals. musulman est un
bon client parce que au plan
communautaire franchement les
responsables musulmans ont pas du tout
les épaules pour
je dirais défendre d'un point de vue
judiciaire et juridique les intérêts de
leur communauté si
en admettant qu'elle existe parce que
moi je sais pas sociologiquement je
serais censé appartenir à la communauté
musulmane mais je sais pas ce que c'est
si vous voulez jamais quand j'étais
étudiant et je galérais il y a un type
qui m'a disait je suis le responsable de
ta communauté puis je vais t'aider à
finir tes études tiens voilà un chèque
Ça m'est pas arrivé quand je me retrouve
dans mes galères administratives.
Pourtant, pour avoir lutté contre le
racisme antimusulman, j'ai jamais été
contacté par par bien au contraire, j'ai
jamais été contacté par des responsables
musulmans et bien au contraire, la
plupart ont plutôt coupé les liens. On a
au CFCM un vieux un serpent de mer là
qui qui chargeait de la lutte contre
l'islamophobie. Je l'ai appelé, je lui
ai dit tiens bah voilà, j'ai dénoncé le
racisme antimusulman au centre de
rétention. Euh est-ce que je peux avoir
un communiqué de solidarité du CFCM ?
Allez là. Voilà, les faits sont là, il y
a des photos et cetera, c'est
incontestable. Le type me dit "Ah
c'était Bruno Lerou à l'époque. Je vois
le ministre de l'intérieur demain
après-midi, je lui en parle." Je lui dis
"Non, non, c'est pas ce que je te
demande. Je te demande de rédiger un
communiqué écrit et de le diffuser. Je
veux pas après si tu veux parler au
ministre de l'intérieur demain
après-midi, tu lui parles, il y a aucun
souci." Il me dit "Bah vas-y, est-ce que
tu peux, je te donne mon mail, tu
m'envoies les éléments par mail et euh
et puis euh je les étudie et je rédige
le communiquer." Je pense que ça doit
faire quelque chose comme 2 ans et demi
à peu près que j'attends le communiquer.
Voilà. Quand on va apprendre l'arabe en
mosquée, c'est normal qu'on se fasse un
peu épier par les services de
renseignement ou pas ?
Quand on veut apprendre l'arabe dans les
mosquées. Bon, je pense pas que je pense
pas que les services de renseignement et
pillont apprendre l'arabe dans les
mosquées. Non, je pense pas que ce soit
parmi leurs préoccupations. Si vous
voulez, les mosquées, ça a été une
culture pendant les années 90, pendant
toute la période GIA et cetera. On avait
des personnes qui se radicalisaient dans
les mosquées. Donc, il y avait des
surveillances qui étaient effectuées
dans les lieux de culte. Mais
aujourd'hui, tout le monde sait avec une
caméra est crois pas. Est-ce qu'on a
déjà monitoré des caméras dans les
mosquées ?
Je crois pas. Non non. Je pense que
c'est les sources humaines qui vont qui
écoutent.
À la limite, si vous voulez euh
verrouiller le truc pour donner un peu
de cohérence parce que la cible est
importante, vous mettez trois ou quatre
sources humaines qui se connaissent pas
naturellement en aveugle et puis vous
faites enregistrer. Vous bon
éventuellement parfois il y a peut-être
des photos qui sont prises avec les
smartphones et cetera, mais sonoriser
caméra et cetera, je pense pas. Je sais
pas moi après une fois j'ai eu un
responsable de mosquée qui m'a appelé
après ma faire de renseignement qui me
dit voilà je je je bon j'ai peur qu'on
me soupçonne et cetera moi je suis
transparent vis-à-vis des pouvoirs
publics qu'est-ce que je peux faire je
dis bah tuinstalles la vidéos
surveillance de ta mosquée tu sonorises
toi-même ta mosquée chaque prêche du
vendredi tu le consignes en vidéo et en
son et tu l'envoies toi-même à la
préfecture. comme ça, c'est une preuve
de transparence. C'est pas la p
par la loi ça.
Bah oui, à partir du moment où vous
notez sur la porte d'entrée, cet endroit
est fait placé sous vidéosurveillance
avec un œil là, vous savez, c'est c'est
souvent le cas dans les commerces et
cetera, bah la vidéo surveillance est
totalement légale dès lors que les gens
qui figurent sur les bandes sont avertis
au préalable de de la vidéosurveillance.
J'ai dit bah pourquoi tu la diffuses sur
internet, tu crées un site et puis voilà
Hotba le nom de en direct éventuellement
tu la mets à disposition de la
préfecture, tu préviens et puis voilà et
comme ça bah il y a pas d'ambiguïté. Si
quelqu'un un jour un service deement dit
oui tu as appelé à la haine ou quoi que
ce soit, bah tu diras quelle date, quel
instant bah voilà on repasse les membes.
Mais si vous êtes toujours dans la
dissimulation, dans la peu près, dans la
crainte, bah à ce moment-là, il y aura
jamais d'émancipation. Mais après bon,
comme je vous dis, c'est des gens la
plupart du temps qui sont pas vraiment à
la hauteur de de leur mission hein, très
objectivement.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Tarik
Ramadon ?
Pas grand-chose si ce n'est que bon
voilà, c'est il a toujours nié les liens
idéologiques avec les frères musulmans.
Bon, je pense que c'est c'est c'était
inutile. C'est clairement un héritier de
la doctrine. Après, il a peut-être pas
de responsabilité administrative et
officielle dans le parti des frères
musulmans, mais il est partisan de ce
parti. Maintenant, je pense qu'au départ
vous avez fait expulser son frère. Non,
c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait expulser,
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur. Mais
moi, je l'ai repéré son frère. En fait,
je l'ai repéré sur mon département. Bon,
on va ouvrir une parenthèse. Pourquoi
est-ce que je lui en veux ? Comme ça, il
va écouter. Et parce que moi, j'ai
toujours été honnête avec les gens que
j'ai surveillé. C'est-à-dire que quand
j'allais, j'étais j'étais dépêché
quelque part, je venais en amont de la
Réunion et
je disais aux gens, "Bah voilà, je suis
issu je suis monsieur untel, issu des
services de renseignement et je me
présente à vous pour parce qu'on m'a
demandé de venir assister à la Réunion."
Donc lui, je l'ai vu un jour, il était
pendant un repas du midi et il allait
entrer en repas. C'est au salon du
Bourget. Je dis "Monsieur, bonjour, je
suis un tel et monsieur Ramadan donc et
puis je je souhaiterai vous voir après
le repas." Il me dit "Oui, OK, tu
t'assois là, t'inquiète pas, j'arrive."
Et donc j'attends 1h30 et au bout d'une
heure et3, il discute, il discute avec
la personne avec qui il mange et il fait
comme si j'étais pas là. Bon, je me dis
soit c'est peut-être mal poli de ma
part, il est en train de manger, je le
prends pour moi, c'est il y a pas de
souci, je lui en veux pas. Donc le
lendemain soir, j'y vais, il y a la
réunion qui a qui a couronjour monsieur,
vous souvenez de moi ? Il me dit "Oui,
peut-être." Et donc je lui dis bah
voilà, je suis dans la salle. En fait
là, la réunion ne venait de passer,
c'était pas préalable. C'était après la
réunion que je suis allé le voir, après
la conférence qui venait de donner. Et
il venait de dire aux gens justement,
aimez votre pays, vous êtes intégré à
l'Europe, vous avez vocation à vous
intégrer, vous verrez, essayez d'occuper
des fonctions dans les institutions et
cetera. Je dis "Bah ça tombe bien
justement. Je suis le représentant de la
préfecture sur place." C'est-à-dire que
c'est moi qui suis chargé de surveiller
et en tout cas qui suis chargé en tout
cas de d'évaluer le niveau de sécurité
sur la sur la manifestation par le
préfet. Il me dit "Ah, il y avait un
petit groupe autour de lui, il me dit
"C'est toi qui est là pour le préfet ?"
Et puis je vois les mecs se mettent à
récaner. Il me voit parce que j'étais
habillé en jean. J'étais avec ma
doudoune. Il me dit "Est-ce que tu le
connais le préfet ? Est-ce que tu l'as
déjà croisé ?" Je dis "Monsieur, vous
plaisantez ?" avec un air très ironique.
En fait, il m' en fait il m'a pris pour
un débile et euh un moment je voyais que
les gens autour de lui commençaient à
ricaner, vous voyez, à rire un petit
peu. Euh je dis bon là on est carrément
dans l'irrespect. Donc je lui sors la
carte de réquisition, je dis "Bon
monsieur police, vous allez me suivre et
puis on va on va on va cesser la
plaisanterie parce que moi je suis en
train de travailler, j'ai pas le temps
de plaisanter." Et là il vient d'un coup
puis il essaie de me flatter. Il me dit
"Ah mais on sent chez toi une certaine
sagesse, ça me rappelle des choses la
police turque magnifique et cetera." En
fait, il me caresse dans le sens du poil
parce qu'il s'aperçoit qu'il a fait une
connerie. Et donc, je lui dis bon voilà,
maintenant vous avez compris. Donc
voilà, je viens d'assister à votre
conférence, c'est curieux. Je lui ai
dit, je lui dis "Vous dites aux gens
d'occuper des places et cetera, aux
jeunes et puis quand il y en a un qui
arrive, vous foutez de sa gueule." Et
donc, c'est sympa le double discours.
Bon, en fait, après bon, je voyais qu'il
était un peu confus et donc l'année
suivante, j'y vais et le mec je lui
parle et puis je lui dis "Bon voilà, je
viens, vous avez une conférence tout
aussi, donc je vais y assister." Et en
fait le mec me parle mais il continue à
marcher. Il prend pas la peine de
s'arrêter pour moi. Et donc je me dis
bon le mec en fin de compte il a un vrai
problème avec ça. Donc bon du coup je me
dis bah il y a pas de raison que en fin
de compte compte tenu tenur de son
discours et cetera. C'est pas un mec
sincère, c'est pas un mec franc. Alors
que normalement la religion ça vous
apprend justement la franchise, la
sincérité, la biencéance. Donc là le
mail se comporte de façon carrément
irrespectueuse. Donc il tient un
discours qui l'applique pas. Je me dis
bah ça peut pas être quelqu'un
d'honnête. Donc moi je l'ai perçu comme
ça et ensuite bon ben une ou deux
conférences, il a continué à dépasser
les limites, on l'a signalé quoi. C'est
tout hein. C'est le mec justifiait la
lapidation euh euh il faisait la
promotion des des frères musulmans
Mohamed Mory. Donc le le jeune du 93 qui
est dans sa galère, qui est au chômage
et cetera, vous arrivez, vous lui dites
: "En Égypte, il faut remettre Morci
parce que il a été renversé." Bon, vous
voyez, est-ce qu'il y a pas d'autres
priorités dans la vie quoi ? Je veux
dire, bon c'est c'était pas opportun.
Voilà. Donc après cette ARC bon ces
phrases qui été connues depuis de
longues dates qu'en tant que citoyen,
bon hormis le viol qui se prononcera
là-dessus quand vous vous présentez
comme leader religieux vous êtes quand
même garant d'une morale religieuse. Il
le sait très bien. Donc un moment vous
voyez si vous êtes libertin, vous je
sais pas vous êtes libertin peut-être
que vous voule, peut-être que moi je le
suis, on sait pas, on est libre voyez.
Mais dans ce cas là, il faut se garder
de faire la morale aux gens. Dites pas
aux gens de pas aller à la piscine parce
qu'il faut porter un maillot de bain
alors que vous vous êtes de votre côté
adepte, je sais pas, du sadomageisme ou
je sais pas quoi avec des femmes marié
peut-être des des adolescents ou je ne
sais quoi. Vous voyez des histoires, il
faut toujours faire la part un tri entre
les informations qui arrivent, ce qui
est de l'ordre de la rumeur, ce qui ce
qui est avéré. Mais de toute façon,
c'est quelqu'un qui avait un problème
avec la la parole libre, c'est-à-dire
que il avait dépêché des avocats service
juridique où dès que les gens écrivaient
sur les forum ou quoi que ce soit, les
gens qui recevaient un message en disant
"Je suis l'avocat de Tarik Ramadan, vous
avez écrit telle chose à tel endroit,
donc vous êtes menacé de poursuite
judiciaire." Il avait peur de la parole
libre. C'est quelque chose qu'il tentait
d'étouffer depuis des années et donc
naturellement il s il a été pris à son
propre jeu. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous connaissez l'euro
Jeanfort ? Vous en pensez quoi ?
Pardon ?
L'euro Jeanfort ? Ça me dit rien.
C'est la patrouille de gendarmerie
européenne. Euh
pas du tout.
Non, pas du tout. Alors là, sur tout ce
qui est institution européenne et
cetera, je suis pas je suis pas au top.
Alors, question d'internet sur les
manifestations. Que pensez-vous des
marqueurs chimiques en manifestation ?
Écoutez, c'est un principe qui existe de
longue date qui qui était automatisé au
départ, c'estàdire que c'était un
dispositif anticambriolage.
Donc c'est c'est en fait ça utilise une
forme d'ADN, ce qu'on appelle que
c'est-à-dire que bon, c'est un marqueur
chimique qui est invisible et
globalement qui permet de vous
confondre. C'estàd que si vous avez des
soupçons de cambriolage ou quoi que ce
soit, bah ça permettait de de manifester
en tout cas votre d'attester de votre
présence sur les lieux. Donc maintenant,
c'est toujours pareil, c'est comme le
LBD et cetera, c'est que bon, s'il y a
des casseurs, effectivement, on peut les
marquer grâce à je sais pas par quel
vecteur justement le le l'ADN va être
propagé, mais il faut cibler les bonnes
personnes et ensuite bon bah pourquoi
est-ce qu'on veut les marquer
chimiquement ? Est-ce qu'on peut pas les
interpeller sur place ? À la limite, si
vous avez la possibilité de de les
marquer avec du chimique, bah autant les
interpeller, j'ai envie de dire.
Peut-être il y a peut-être un défaut de
moyen, je sais pas. Voyez, il faudrait
préciser un peu la la on va dire la
teneur de l'utilisation de ce principe
peut-être pour éviter d'aller au contact
tout de suite.
Et alors bah c'est dans ce cas-là,
qu'est-ce qui vous permet d'identifier
les gens et d'aller les chercher après ?
Autant aller les chercher tout de suite.
Voyez, si on veut faire le distingo
entre les casseurs et les gilets jaunes,
autant aller chercher les casseurs
directement sur place. Quel est
l'intérêt de leur tirer dessus ou de le
leur propager du gaz s'ils sont devant
vous ? Vous les interpellez. Je quoi je
en tout cas il faudrait préciser mais je
il doit y avoir une logique mais
éventuellement je je
voilà bon je pense que vous avez compris
le sens de ma réponse.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
de
d'éléments perturbateurs contrôlés dans
les manifestations d'agents d'agents
perturbateurs d'agents provocateurs ?
Non,
des fonctionnaires de police déguisés en
manifestant qui s'amusent à casser pour
tout le monde. C'est vrai, c'est pas
vrai ?
Non, non, moi j'y crois pas beaucoup.
Non, honnêtement, il y a il y a des gens
qui vous diront "Oui, j'ai vu des vidéos
qui attestent et cetera." Moi, j'y crois
pas. Que des personnes puissent recevoir
l'ordre de la part de leur hiérarchie de
participer à des activités délictueuses.
Il y a plein de défauts dans la police
et croyez-moi, chez Vigi, on est les
premiers à dénoncer ce qui s'y passe en
terme de bon, je vais pas revenir sur
tout ce que j'ai dénoncé mais ça
honnêtement, je pense qu'il faut raison
garder le complotisme et cetera.
Franchement, je pense que c'est c'est
pas grandir la cause des gilets jaunes
que de que de propager ce type
d'information comme pour les t-shirts
volés par le CRS et cetera. C'était un
fake. C'estàd que le type était là en
train de collecter justement des pièces
à conviction. Quand bien même, je pense
que si une personne avait voulu voler,
il l'aurait pas fait de cette façonlà de
façon apparente devant les autres. La
seule chose que je peux reprocher,
c'est le coup dans la caméra collègue,
c'est voilà le coup dans la caméra.
C'està-dire que si comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure, ce qui est
valable pour les citoyens est valable
pour nous les policiers aussi. Si vous
vous estimez irréprochable, vous n'alz
pas avoir peur de la surveillance, de la
vidéosurveillance et cetera. Donc voilà.
Bon euh
là c'est c'est déluel he frapper comme
ça dans la main. La force c'est l'usage
de la force et la légitime défense. Il y
a pas d'autres cadres d'usage de la
force. Donc là c'était pas le cas.
La la BAC qui est qui est projetée sur
les théâtres de manifestation pour faire
du maintien de l'ordre. quand on les
voit débarquer un peu en mode "J'ai fait
ma séance de paintball pendant
l'après-midi et j'avance d'une façon
comme des débutants
avancé en petite patrouille de
paintballurs. On les voit bien. Vous
avez jamais fait du paintball ? Quand
vous voyez l'équipe des bacs se balader
dans les manifestations, on a
l'impression qu'il joue au paint ball
mais qui jouent au paintball comme des
des mecs qui ont rêvé d'être militair
mais qui sont pas militaires mais qui se
prennent pour des militaires quand même.
Non mais vous savez, nous on a
Non, vous avez pas l'impression de les
voir comme ça quand il se baladent un
petit peu qu' jou cowboy un peu mitigé.
Moi, vous savez, je risque bon, vous
connaissez mes positions, elles sont
sincères depuis le début de du conflit
des gilets jaunes. C'est les mêmes que
celles d'Alexandre Langlois Aond. Chez
Vigi, on est solidaire par rapport à ces
positions là des gilets jaunes. J'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour mes collègues
de bac parce qu'honnêtement, il faut un
sale boulot quand même. Honnêtement,
vous allez en banlieu, non franchement,
vous allez en banlieu, vous voyez la
façon dont ils sont pris à partie,
insulter les les dossiers qu'ils vont
aller chercher, c'est-à-dire aller dans
les immeubles, dans les cités, ils font
de tout. C'està-dire que ils font du
SDF. qui font franchement c'est un
boulot de dingue honnêtement c'est de
moi je leur tire mon chapeau parce que
franchement euh garder la tête sur les
épaules en faisant ce boulot là ça
mérite quand même. Ou
d'accord ils font assistante sociale
dans les cages d'escalier OK mais les
projeter dans
les projeter les projeter dans les
justement ils sont mobilisés sur des
choses peut-être sur lesquelles ils
devraient pas être mais ils le font
quand même. Et donc à un moment, moi
vous savez
ce midi, j'entendais un de mes collègues
syndicalistes d'un autre syndicat qui
était dans le JT à qui on demandait
est-ce que voilà Castaner est
responsable ? dis mais non Castoner est
pas responsable que vous métiez lui ou
un autre ça va et puis il se déchanait
un peu sur le préfet de police. Vous
voyez c'est la voie gouvernementale. Il
y a des syndicat on a des collègues
syndicalistes qui ont accepté de porter
la voie gouvernementale en échange. Je
pense qu'il y a du deal vous voyez il y
a des facilités en matière de ressources
humaines. Il y a bon c'est c'est un
choix qu'ils ont fait. Mais on reconnaît
quelqu'un les je pense que les les
téléspectateurs sont pas stupides. On
reconnaît très bien quelqu'un qui vend
son âme au diable. Il y a un tracte d'un
syndicat d'officier qui est sorti
avant-hier qui a un tract
il parle de vermine ou de je sais pas
quoi.
Ouais. Voilà. Qui c'est c'est pas
professionnel manifestation manifestant
mélanchonniste.
Oui. Puis qui qualifie le défenseur des
droits de de sénilissime
défenseur des droits et cetera. C'est là
on est dans l'injure, vous voyez un type
du café des sports aurait pas écrit un
truc pareil quoi. Donc et là c'est un
track d'un syndicat d'officier,
c'estàdire du commandement de la police
nationale. Donc vous dites bon euh là ça
a dépassé toute mesure à la limite je
bon de toute façon je il faut tomber les
masques. On voit bien qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'éditorialistes, de
fonctionnaires, de syndicats et cetera,
pas que dans la police qui se sont
portés partisans de la République en
marche. Et donc aujourd'hui, il s'agit
d'une bataille rangée entre les
partisans et les opposants. Sauf que
certains enfilent des déguisements de
syndicalistes, policiers, d'autres et
cetera. Mais pour moi, quand vous avez,
vous savez en droit des assurances ou
quoi que ce soit, quand vous avez un
véhicule qui fonce dans un mur, dans une
remarde ou dans un autre véhicule, bah
c'est le conducteur qui est responsable.
Vous voyez, c'est pas le passager. Si le
conducteur dit "Non, mais le passager
est en train de me parler à ce
moment-là, il m'a touché le bras et
cetera, ça marche pas." vous êtes
conducteur d'un véhicule, vous acceptez
la responsabilité de ce qui s'y passe et
des éventuels incidents. Donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui, on essaie de détourner
le débat. Bon, effectivement, c'est fait
de façon très subtile, hein, mais en
tout cas a priori, moi je m'y trompe
pas. Voilà. Après, les bacs, c'est un
faux débat, moi je les laisse
tranquille. Ils font un travail
difficile comme je vous l'ai dit. Si on
estime qu'ils vont pas être là, bah dans
ce cas-là, il y a des gendarmes mobiles,
il y a des CRS, il y a des compagnies
d'intervention qui s dirigent pour ça.
En parlant des compagnies
d'intervention, mais qu'on a à la
famille de notre collègue de la 22e C
qui s'est suicidé cette nuit.
À son âme. Euh, si je vous disf,
oui, c'est bon, vous voyez, c'est un peu
les gadgets. On vous parliez du gaz tout
à l'heure, du traceur. Donc là, le KCK,
c'est pareil. C'est bon, vous avez des
débiles sur internet qui qui ont qui
expriment une certaine forme de rancur à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre et qui
trouvent amusant de faire de de ça de
s'adonner à ce genre de jeu pour jeter
de l'huile sur le feu. Vous savez, j'ai
quand sur mon sur mon Twitter, j'ai j'ai
parlé du collègue qui s'était suicidé.
Il y a eu deux personnes tout à l'heure
ce midi, je regardais les réponses qui
disaient bien fait un de moins et
cetera.
Moi, je crois que ce qui nous rassemble,
moi en tout cas ce qui me lie au
militants gilets jaunes, ça c'est
l'humanité si vous voulez. Donc ce qui
me liit à mes collègues policiers
aujourd'hui, c'est aussi l'humanité en
disant "Attendez, quand je vois un
collègue qui tabasse à coup de point ou
à coup de matraque, un vieux de 70 ans,
un vieux Berichon qui a fait le
déplacement jusqu'à Paris. J'ai envie
d'aller voir dire "Colèg qu'est-ce que
tu fais là ? Attends, le mec il a 70
balet, tu lui donnes des coups de
matraque, qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ? Un
moment, vous voyez, moi j'ai cette
position de médiateur euh en tout cas
dans dans ce conflit là. Je suis pas là
pour condamner les uns ou les autres,
mais essayer de de vous voyez de de de
remettre un petit peu de raison dans
tout ça. Et donc le Kakatov, c'est
pareil, j'ai envie de dire mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette connerie
quoi franchement c'est même Éric Drou
qui s'est passé. Bon aller chez lui, on
touche pas au domicile des gens. Il y a
les enfants, il y a les femmes et
cetera. Soit il y a eu l'incendie
effectivement en bas de la banque, mais
tout ça c'est pareil, c'est un peu
instrumentalisé, il faut le condamner
naturellement. Mais faire de la com
là-dessus comme sur la plaque de jugelé,
franchement bon effectivement c'est
horrible ce qui s'est passé. Le mec qui
a qui a donné un coup de bombe sur de
spray peinture sur la plaque de jugelé,
c'est c'est vraiment la dernière des
vermines, des raclures de de fond de
cuvettes, quoi. Mais c'est un mec, un
manifestant qui a donné un coup de
spray. Donc bon, c'est sûr qu'il y a une
offense à la mémoire de notre collègue,
mais moi je pose des vraies questions.
Je je dis "OK, on veut faire un
rassemblement et cetera, on a le droit
de le faire."
Par contre, celui qui l'a tué Shurfy euh
il a été mis en évidence par la presse
qu'il avait violé son contrôle
judiciaire en janvier. Il a je crois que
l'assassinat a été commis en mars. En
janvier, il a passé des vacances en
Algérie alors qu'il était sous contrôle
judiciaire et il est revenu. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'on l'a pas placé en détention
? Si on l'avait placé en détention,
peut-être qu'il aurait pas tué notre
collègue. Voyez, ça c'est c'est un vrai
débat. Après bon la plaque effectivement
là on est dans les l'instantané
émotif c'est-à-dire il y a eu la plaque
et cetera, on organise un rassemblement
et ça c'est pareil, c'est de la com
gouvernementale.
Après bon, je profite de l'antenne
naturellement pour adresser à son mari
mes mes encore une fois mes condoléances
parce que c'est un deuil natur, c'est
une blessure, je dirais qui qu'il
cicatrise pas mais quelque part c'est
indébile et justement pourquoi est-ce
qu'on l'a pas interpellé sur le moment
puisqu'on avait 4600 fonctionnaires sur
place, 12 compagnies de CRS qui étaient
cantonné en bas de l'Élysée.
Moi, j'aurais je vous voyez moi je suis
policier donc moi je suis plutôt dans
l'offensive en fait dire bah le mec qui
a fait ça pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'en est
tiré ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'a laissé
faire ça ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a mis
12 escadrons de CRS en bas à l'Élysée ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pas mis un CRS
devant la plaque pour protéger la plaque
? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pas recouvert
avant ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a laissé
du mobilier urbain là des de chantiers,
des barrières et cetera sur les
Champs-Élysées ?
Vous soulevez quelque chose de très
intéressant. quand
un manifestant est est monitoré toute la
journée et que on peut noter heure par
heure, minute par minute, ce qu'il a
dégradé, ce qu'il a cassé, ce qu'il a
bousillé et qu'on le laisse faire.
C'est quoi ? C'est favoriser les
casseurs pour ensuite prendre le
contrôle de la communication.
Non mais en fait, il y avait une
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre qui
convenait pas. C'est qu'après le 1er
mai, on avait déjà eu un premier
scandale où déjà la place du préfet de
police de bon qui était le même jusqu'à
cette semaine avait été un peu fragilisé
quand le McDo avait été brûlé par
justement par les blacks, le McDo du 5e
là qui se trouvait
près du jardin des plantes. Bon, c'est à
l'époque la le préfet de police avait
assumé en disant bah notre doctrine
c'est zéro mort, zéro blessés dans la
mesure du possible et puis tant pis pour
les dégâts matériels. on s'est bien
aperçu que ça ça commença à chiffrer et
que c'était une doctrine qui en terme de
communication était pas forcément
payante pour la majorité.
Euh et donc naturellement
bon bah il a fallu en changer. Après on
va voir ce qui ce qui ce qui nous est
réservé pour la suite tout simplement.
On va s'envoyer deux trois petites
questions d'internet. H
euh
alors que pouvez-vous nous expliquer des
attentats du G du GIA sur le sol
français
rue Mira Rer Saint-Michel. Ah oui, alors
ça effectivement alors ça mérite un
chapitre à part entière et donc je suis
en train de le concentrer dans mes
mémoires puisque naturellement je
m'aperçois que bon moi j'ai été formé
par les gens qui ont travaillé sur cette
enquête à l'époque naturellement je
devais j'étais au lycée he à l'époque
j'ai j'ai quoi je vois je j'ai j'étais
étudiant à cette époque-là donc j'étais
pas encore affecté au service de police
mais les gens qui m'ont formé au
renseignement euh m' et eux ont
travaillé sur cette enquête et donc je
concentre ça dans mes mémoires euh
apparaître dans les prochains mois.
C'est-à-dire que je suis en train de
concentrer mes mémoires, les formaliser
et j'en je profite de votre tête, c'est
la première fois que j'en parle donc je
les soumettrai à à la DGPN et euh donc
je les proposerai à un éditeur
direction général de la police.
Voilà. Tout à fait. Je les proposerai à
un éditeur et donc vous aurez
effectivement ce qui m'a le détail de ce
qui m'a été livré à cette période.
Donc pas de
pas de révélation aujourd'hui mais
un petit apéritif, un petit spoil quand
même.
Euh disons que je dirais que toutes les
vagues d'attentat, toutes les vagues
importantes d'attentat en France ont été
précédées par un signal similaire.
C'està-dire que la Rumira, ça a été en
fin de compte le premier acte de la
vague d'attentat qui nous a touché dans
les années 90. l'assassinat de l'imam
Saroui donc à coup de brenec he deux
coups de brenec dans la tête donc autant
dire que il devait pas en rester
grand-chose après un monsieur de 83 ans
il me semble et donc avant l'11
septembre 2 jours avant le commandant
Massou donc Hervé Gourdel avant avant la
vague d'attentat Charlie Hebdo qui a
toujours eu de toute façon ce type de
d'annonce avant donc voilà c'est c'est
ce sera l'apéritif la suite à venir.
Les terroristes aiment bien mourir le
vendredi soir parce que ça fait plus
d'audience ou parce que
pas que le vendredi soir. vendredi en
journée, c'est pas que ça fait plus
d'audience, c'est que
en fin de compte ce qui est raconté en
tout cas un candidat au martyr, c'est
l'idée que il accéderait au paradis
suprême justement au statut de martyre
et donc il est recommandé dans la
tradition prophétique pas forcément pour
les martyres he mais en tout cas pour le
martyre offensif de de mourir le
vendredi parce que le vendredi est
considéré comme le jour sain de l'islam,
le samedi pour les juifs, le dimanche
pour les catholiques, donc pour les
chrétiens en général. Voilà. Donc c'est
c'est ça fait partie de la doctrine de
l'eschatologie islamique. Et donc ça a
été un mode opératoire pendant certains
temps mais comme le but naturellement
c'est d'essayer d'être imprévisible. Ça
c'est un peu estompé avec le temps.
Autre question internet. Vous vous
définissez comme lanceur d'alerte.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à sortir du
rang ? Si vous parlez aujourd'hui, c'est
que vous avez été placardisé.
Vous allez être viré.
Je sais pas. La personne dit que je vais
être viré ou elle pose la question ?
C'est une question.
Écoutez moi c'est un c'est une forme de
vexation en fait qui m'a fait sortir un
petit peu du rang. C'est pas forcément
mes intérêts là. Là je pense que j'agis
contre mes intérêts personnels hein.
Très honnêtement.
Vous agissez peut-être pour l'intérêt
général.
Tout à fait.
Donc vous êtes un bon flic.
Je sais pas si vous le dites. Je vous
crois sur parole mais c'est pas à moi de
le dire en tout cas. Maintenant euh
j'ai bien compris si vous voulez. Bon à
un moment on m'a reproché quelque chose
à la DRPP. Je vous parlais de Nicolas de
Lève tout à l'heure qui était l'adjoint
au chef de service. J'ai accepté le
reproche, vous voyez. Je suis pourtant
je le fais difficilement parce que
j'essaie toujours de faire de mon mieux.
Donc quand on me reproche des choses,
parfois ça peut m'atteindre un petit peu
dans mon ego, mais je me dis bon, la
personne a peut-être raison et je vais
essayer de m'enrichir de ce qu'elle me
dit dès lors qu'elle est de bonne foi.
C'està-dire que une personne qui vous
critique, si elle le fait de bonne foi,
quelque part, elle vous rend service.
Mais malheureusement, quand vous êtes
arabe, musulman dans la société
française, vous devez cultiver une sorte
de 6e sens pousse à vous interroger sur
la personne qui vous fait une critique.
Est-ce qu'elle le fait pour m'emmerder
ou est-ce qu'elle le fait pour me
corriger ? Et à ce moment-là, vous
validez ou pas ? et vous prenez un
risque. Et quelque part, bon quand mon
collègue,
bon, j'en avais parlé dans dans le média
mais est venu me dire "Ben, on t'a mis
en écoute sur écoute en 2011 alors que
j'ai été noté 7/ 7 dans l'administration
aller chercher des fonctionnaires." Je
vais vous dire bon c'est je vous dis ça
en toute modestime, on n'est pas très
nombreux à avoir été noté 7/ 7 pendant 3
4 5 ans d'affilé. J'étais noté 7/ 7.
J'étais dévoué cors et âme à mon
institution. Je prenais sur mon temps.
J'avais une fille euh ma de ma ma 2uxè
petite qui avait reçu un diagnostic très
malheureusement euh très préoccupant au
plan médical. Donc euh et pourtant
j'avais euh donné euh toute mon énergie,
mes soirées, mes weekends à
l'institution policière. Et malgré ça,
on a vu en moi l'arabe, le musulman et
on a décidé de me placer sur écoute. Et
un jour, le jour où on a estimé qu'on
s'était suffisamment servi de moi, ils
ont essayé de me déstabiliser par une
procédure judiciaire, un truc bidon, un
différent de de voisinage pour lequel
j'étais relaxé.
Et quand j'ai été relaxé, mon patron est
venu me voir, il m'a dit "Bon, en gros,
on n' pas réussi à te sabrer de cette
façon, mais par contre, on va pas se
chercher des pou pendant des mois, il
faut que tu quittes le service." Donc
voilà, il m'a dit "Allez travailler dans
Valdoise, au renseignement du Valdoise."
Je lui ai dit "Écoutez, avec tout mon
respect, vous votre devoir ou votre
droit, en tout cas le plus absolu, c'est
de vous dire, en tout cas de me notifier
que vous ne voulez plus travailler avec
moi. C'est votre droit. Mais par contre,
me dire où je vais aller, ça vous
concerne pas avec tout mon respect. Je
pense qu'il l'a mal pris et donc du coup
partout où j'ai postulé, il a opposé un
véto et euh donc bon donc après je suis
allé à la PAF par despis et bon il s'en
est suivi ce que je vous ai raconté tout
à l'heure, c'est-à-dire tentative en
tout cas de mise au placard de
déstabilisation contre laquelle je me
suis défendu. Après
je suis pas un peu heureux en fait,
c'est pas dans mon ADN. C'est-à-dire que
moi je voyez si aujourd'hui on me dit
bah écoute la police française c'est la
police
je sais pas de Corée du Nord ou quoi que
ce soit donc c'est kif kif il y a pas de
droit de l'homme ou quoi que ce soit tu
oublies euh je suis gradé je suis ton
chef j'ai raison
dans ce cas-là je sais à quoi m'entenir
mais si on me chante les droits de
l'homme tous les jours et à côté de ça
je m'aperçois que finalement le système
est complètement sclérosé bon ben c'est
une déception et à ce moment-là Là, je
me réserve le droit de faire autre chose
parce que si je me suis engagé dans la
police, la c'est pas pour la sécurité de
l'emploi. Je pouvais aussi réussir le
concours de la poste à la SNCF et
cetera. J'aurais pu l'emploi, il y en a
l'emploi stable, il existe un petit peu
partout mais c'est que quelque part je
me suis prêté au jeu finalement de d'un
idéal et bon force de constater hein
depuis ma saisine de l'IGPN que ça
marche pas comme je l'espérais.
C'est-à-dire que il y a un certain
nombre d'auditions, de bilans qui
renferment des mensonges ouverts et
aujourd'hui je leur dis bah quel est mon
recours contre les mensonge de l'IGPN ?
On dit c'est le conseil de discipline,
tu iras et puis tu te défendras. Mais
quand on sait comment fonctionnent les
conseils de discipline clairement là ma
tête est sur une guillotine. Après
est-ce que je vais être viré ou pas ?
J'en sais rien.
Après vous savez j'ai confiance en
l'avenir. On verra. De toute façon, je
pense que mon avenir dans la police
nationale est compromis. Quoi qu'il en
soit, le placard m'intéresse pas
forcément parce qu'il me reste 20 ans à
tirer. Comme je vous l'ai dit, j'ai 43
ans, donc il me reste 20 ans d'exercice.
Maintenant, j'ai d'autres projet, je
souhaite me maintenir dans la police
nationale, peut-être en disponibilité,
on verra. Mais en tout cas, je ferai
d'autres tentatives. Ouais, je d'autres
expériences.
Autre question internet avec du recul.
Qu'avez-vous pensé de la faire Tarnac ?
Est-ce une utilisation de
l'antiterroriste pour lutter contre les
opposants politiques ?
B naturellement ça a été beaucoup de
beaucoup de bruit pour pas grand-chose
finalement pour aboutir il me semble il
y a quelques mois une relaxe de de
Julien Coupa et d'un Lévi. Bon
est-ce qu'on pouvait vraiment parler de
terrorisme ? Voyez quand vous êtes
bande de bran qui ont inventé des
preuves pour se faire briller auprès de
leur chef. Est-ce que c'est pas une
bande de branque qui voulait fournir une
petite sucette à leur ministère de
l'intérieur qui venait fraîchement
d'être investi ? Oui, je crois qu'on est
bon je j'ai pas les détails de la
procédure, mais je pense qu'il y avait
quelque chose bah la justice le démontre
aujourd'hui, quelque chose de cet
ordre-là. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui,
on sait que les services de
renseignement sont susceptibles de de
porter des accusations, de fumenter des
des preuves en tout cas contre
à charge contre des personnes.
Fin sédicieux,
écoutez, je sais pas. Mais ceci dit, en
tout cas, ce qu'on sait, c'est que ce
type de procédure a tout à fait est tout
à fait en capacité de broyer des vies,
des carrières. Et moi, j'ai bien
conscience aujourd'hui que ma carrière
est broyée. C'est-à-dire que comment
est-ce que je vais me relever de ce
qu'ils sont en train de me faire ? Je
sais très bien que c'est terminé. C'est
que je peux rester brigadier.
Effectivement, si je me tiens à carreau,
on va mettre dans un petit commissariat,
dans une truc, dans le meilleur des cas,
j'ai envie de dire. Mais très
clairement, le système administratif est
parfois judiciaire et fait de sorte de
toute façon de de toujours ressortir
vainqueur. C'estàdire que vous regardez
par exle ce qui s'est passé il y a 2
semaines. L'exemple le plus concret sur
l'affaire Benala.
Il y avait eu donc toutes ces affaires
de mise à disposition des des images de
vidéos surourveillance par les
responsables de la DOPC.
Euh donc et ensuite il y a eu
l'audience, c'est-à-dire bon ces
fameuses bandes son qui sont sorties de
chez Mediapart
qui ont qui ont conduit la la le chef de
la chef la commissaire du GSPM à
démissionner et s'en est suivi
l'audience au tribunal qui est le 19 il
me semble que c'était le 19 février de
mémoire au soir et ensuite le lendemain
dans la presse vous avez un nouveau
scandale. On vous donc Benala et Cras
devait s'expliquer
sur la violation de leur contrôle
judiciaire qui leur imposait de se
présenter au commissariat tous les jours
mais également de ne pas entrer en
contact l'un avec l'autre et là 1 heure
avant la comparition on les met dans la
même jaule alors que le tribunal de
Paris vous l'avez vu au Bignol vous êtes
passé devant à plusieurs reprises. C'est
un bâtiment qui est énorme et on n pas
trouvé mieux que de les mettre dans la
même jaôle. Donc ils ont pu
tranquillement discuter, se caler sur
une version à apporter au juges pour
pouvoir l'enfumer. Et donc le juge
naturellement euh ne s'est pas laissé
enfumer. Ils ont été placés en détention
mais ils sont sortis au bout d'une
semaine. Donc ils ont réussi quand même
à être efficaces. Et le lendemain, on a
dit dans la presse que c'était une
bourde, que en fait c'est le mec qui
gère les jaules qui s'est planté. Donc
voilà. Après
moi je crois que c'était tout sauf une
bourde. Bon c'était la DOPC, la DOPC qui
gère les jaules du tribunal aussi mais
c'était pas une bourde. Donc la justice
elle a elle a travaillé sereinement. On
peut pas mettre en cause la justice dans
cette affaire. Les magistrats, ils ont
statué à partir des éléments qu'on leur
apporté, mais la police a donné la
possibilité à Benala et à Crasonner
dans leur réponse qu'ils allaient
apporter à la justice. Voilà, tout
simplement. Et donc bah, résultat de la
course, ils sont gagnants tous les deux.
Donc moi, je vous voyez, j'ai parlé de
l'affaire Benala et cetera dans le cadre
de de l'action qu'on mène à Vigie
puisqu'on est parti civile.
J'ai pris la décision à la suite de
cette affaire de ne plus m'occuper de
l'affaire Benala. C'est j'en ai parlé
sur RT une fois quand on a formulé la
demande de dépaysement mais je m'en
occupe plus, c'est plus la peine, ça
m'intéresse plus. Verrouillé, vous avez
bon, c'est terminé. Voilà,
moi à titre personnel, Vigie va
continuer à s'en occuper. Moi, je sais
pas travailler de cette façon-là. Je
sais pas travailler sur ce type
d'affaire.
C'est une affaire politique.
Apparemment, Media Part a des choses à
nous apprendre. Heureusement qu'ils sont
là d'ailleurs. Voyez, eux comme
d'autres, hein. C'est pas les seuls.
Mais bon, voilà. Moi, je m'occupe pas de
ce type d'affaire. Voyez, je
en France, pays des droits de l'homme
quand même avec des le respect des
procédures judiciaires, de la
déontologie et cetera, là ça dépasse
toutes mes espérances. Donc c'est pas la
peine. Voilà.
Autre questionnet. Vous dites qu'il n'y
a plus d'actualité du terrorisme corse
ou basque. Mais qu'en est-il du
terrorisme d'extrême gauche ?
Existe-t-il un terrorisme anarchiste en
France ? Et des mouvements de sabotage
écologiste ?
Bah, je pense qu'il faut faire attention
aux termes, c'est-à-dire des mouvements
subversifs à potentialité violente.
C'est le terme qu'on utilise en matière
de renseignement. Mouvement subversif à
potentialité violente. OK, mais
terrorisme c'est quand même autre chose.
C'est c'està-dire que moi, j'étais sur
les lieux. J'étais au Stade de France le
13 novembre. Euh bon, j'ai des collèges
qui étaient au Bataclan, j'étais sur les
lieux de Charlie Hebdo aussi un peu
après l'attaque. Donc je sais ce que
c'est que le terrorisme. Donc je demande
aux gens quand même de bon d'arrêter
d'instrumentaliser les termes justement
pour discréditer les opposants ou quoi
que ce soit. Le théorisme c'est quand
même quelque chose d'assez violent.
Aujourd'hui, il y a quand même des
familles en France, si vous avez vu les
reportages et cetera, des parents qui
ont perdu leurs enfants au Bataclan.
Donc là, eux savent ce que c'est que le
terrorisme. Quand vous avez des gars qui
jettent des pavés sur les CRS et ça,
c'est extrêmement grave, mais pour moi,
ça s'appelle pas, c'est pas ce qu'on
appelle du terrorisme.
Des mecs qui mettent des trons d'arbres
sur les voies ferrées
sans doute sans bon, ça c'est ça a dû
arriver mais c'est risqué, c'est
dangereux. Oui, c'est risqué, c'est
dangereux et cetera.
Après le terroriste, c'est quand même la
volonté de tuer, de tuer des de
perpétrer des actions de des meurtres de
masse, vous voyez. Donc
bon, c'est on peut on peut si vous
voulez déployer des moyens d'enquête des
services antiterroristes pour identifier
les coupables. Ça ça me dérange pas.
Mais dire c'est la même chose que ce qui
s'est passé au Bataclan, je pense pas.
Vous voyez, je je je fais quand même une
distinction.
Alors autre question d'internet. Vous
avez dit "Je n'ai rien à cacher." Hm
hm.
La surveillance de masse ne vous
pose-t-il pas un problème ? Et si oui,
à quoi ça sert ?
Bah, si vous voulez euh moi par exemple,
j'habite une ville dans laquelle la
municipalité
s'oppose à des dispositifs à la mise en
place de dispositifs de
vidéosurveillance,
renforcement de la sécurité,
vidéoverbalisation et cetera. Moi, j'y
seraiis pas opposé parce que j'estime
que j'ai rien à me reprocher.
Maintenant, moi je suis pas contre, faut
pas se tromper de débat, je suis pas
contre les moyens, mais c'est comme pour
la déchance de nationalité. Ce pourquoi
le le président de la République à
l'époque avait reculé, c'était parce
qu'il en fait, il redoutait un
détournement finalement de la
législation parce que après ben on peut
retirer la nationalité à des gens qui
finalement seraient pas des terroristes
mais pour des raisons autres. Et donc
les moyens de vidéos surveillance,
d'écoute et cetera, c'est exactement la
même chose. C'estàd que c'est leur
détournement qui pose problème. Et donc
moi, je pense qu'on peut justement
légiférer ou mettre en place des moyens
de surveillance de masse dès lors qu'on
a rien à se reprocher. Mais par contre,
de façon antagoniste, il faut durcir les
sanctions contre d'éventuels
détournements justement de ces moyens de
surveillance. Et aujourd'hui, on en est
pas là si vous voulez. C'est c'est un
peu ce qui pose problème. C'est-à-dire
que moi quand j'ai rencontré un avocat,
j'ai eu un avocat médiatique récemment,
je lu dit "Bah, est-ce que vous pouvez
saisir la commission nationale de
contrôle du renseignement ? Savoir
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai été écouté, par
quoi est-ce que c'était justifié ? S'il
y a des éléments matériels contre moi,
j'accepte la surveillance, il y a aucun
souci. Par contre, s'il y a rien, je
veux que les les décideurs soient
traduits devant la justice. Et l'avocat
me dit "Oh, vous savez, ils sont
difficiles à toucher. Si je leur écris,
je vais me voir notifier une fin de non
recevoir et cetera." le mec m'a
découragé de mener une action avant même
d'avoir commencé. Donc je me dis c'est
pas normal, vous voyez euh c'est quand
vous vous quand il y a une surveillance,
il faut que ce soit consécutif à un
risque à un risque concret sinon c'est
pas la peine. Voilà. Après moi que les
gars ai envie de m'écouter quand je
discute avec mes enfants sur les
horaires du sport, sur les courses et
cetera, ça me dérange pas. Si les gars
ont que ça à faire, tant pis pour eux,
c'est dramatique mais bon ça me dérange
pas.
Excusez-moi,
je vous en prie. Il y a quelque chose de
drôle.
Si ils font des blagues.
Ah d'accord.
Euh euh on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Alors on demande toujours à
nos invité de nous conseiller trois
livres.
Alors
je vous conseillerai Cosmos de Michel
Onf même si j'ai pas encore fini de le
lire. Je j'aime beaucoup cet auteur même
si bon je suis d'accord avec lui à 95 %.
Il y a 5 % on va dire de différents mais
95 % c'est quand même exceptionnel comme
code d'affinité.
Donc euh
j'ai,
je vous dirais imparfait libre et
heureux de Christophe André qui est
l'une de mes idoles. C'estàd quelqu'un
qui a vulgarisé la psychologie et la
psychiatrie moderne, c'estàdire la
psychiatrie la psychologie
comportementale.
C'est un vrai manuel du bonheur
justement.
Et ensuite
j'en là je réfléchis à quelque chose
d'un peu plus police mais temps.
Tous les ouvrages policiers que j'ai lu
récemment les ouvrages sociologiques qui
traitent de ces questions m'ont un petit
peu déçu. En fait, j'aurais envie de
vous dire je vais faire un clin d'œil à
mes origines. Vous choisissez un ouvrage
de Camel Daoud je je dirais Merceau
contre enquête ou n'importe lequel et et
vous piochez parce que Camel Daoud est
excellent. Et de la même manière comme
pour Michel Enfège, je lui je lui donne
une code d'affinité de 99 %.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des de ce
qu'on appelle les bayonnettes
intelligente ?
Je sais pas ce que c'est.
C'est quand on donne un ordre à un
fonctionnaire de police qui est illégal,
il doit se se soustraire ou en assumer
les conséquences pénales.
En général, j'ai envie de dire que les
conseilleurs ne sont pas les payeurs.
Donc quelqu'un qui vous conseille
l'illégalité.
qui vous ordonne
qui vous ordonne l'illégalité. Euh
vous avez ce qu'on appelle l'agression
passive, c'estàdire vous pouvez traîner
les pieds, faire capoter le truc.
euh vous avez plusieurs possibilités de
de désobéir, j'ai envie de dire voilà,
de toujours être dans le compromis parce
que je m'aperçois que pour se constituer
l'anceur d'alerte, il faut avoir les
épaules très larges quand même. Voilà,
je dirais pas je j'ai pas de regrets
particulier mais c'est pas c'est pas
donner à tout le monde. Je dis pas ça
pour jeter les flors, bien au contraire,
mais de de pouvoir résister à la
pression de l'administration par la
suite.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Alors avant de vous poser la dernière
question qui n'est pas une question qui
est laissez un message pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer, un
conseil pour pour les jeunes
générations. Est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on aborde quelque chose d'autre ?
Qu'on aborde quelque chose d'autre à
destination des jeunes ?
Ouais. Non non non. Est-ce que il y a un
sujet que vous voulez qu'on aborde là
avant de laisser votre conseil ?
Je suis un peu pris au dépourvu. Donc je
je dirais que là l'idée j'ai pas j'ai
envie de dire bon que
je dirais que le bon voilà, moi je suis
policier, c'est un travail avant tout,
c'est une vocation mais je dirais qu'il
faut pas se tromper euh
il faut pas se tromper en fin de compte
dans dans les choix dans la hiérarchie
des choix qu'on fait dans la vie si vous
voulez parce que je je pense à mes
collègues qui nous ont quitté ces
dernières semaines. Le travail en fait
est un outil au service du bonheur
familial, de la vie personnelle et pas
l'inverse. Et donc aucune activité,
aucun travail ne justifie ou ne mérite
en tout cas ce choix que l'on peut faire
de se priver justement de vivre en
quelque sorte. Et donc je m'adresse à
mes collègues qui sont en souffrance
dont un en particulier qui s'est adressé
à moi ces derniers jours, qui qui est
malade, qui souffre d'un cancer, forme
de cancer et qui m'a dit "J'attends que
la maladie m'emporte parce qu'il est
malheureux dans son travail." Et j'ai
envie de lui dire
"fuck le travail franchement balaye tout
ça et continue à vivre. Il y a la
famille, les amis, les joies de la de la
vie et si le travail rend malheureux,
ben on peut en changer. C'est difficile
mais c'est dans la tête que ça se passe
justement. et euh
c'est valable pour tous les toutes tous
les types d'activités, c'est-à-dire ne
pas se tromper dans ce qui est important
d'avis, vous savez, moi j'ai j'ai le
média a montré des photos. J'ai côtoyé
plusieurs gouvernements successifs parce
que je les ai protégé en deuxème cercle,
j'ai côtoyé des préfets et cetera et
aujourd'hui quand j'appelle certain
nombre de haut fonctionnaires qui se
reconnaîtront peut-être s'il visionnent
interview, bah quand je vais vous les
appeler aujourd'hui, vous leur envoyez
un message pour les fêtes, ils vous
répondent pas.
C'est voilà des gens qui m'ont demandé
parfois de transgresser la voie
hiérarchique parce qu'ils avaient besoin
de moi, parce qu'ils avaient des
urgences et cetera. Aujourd'hui, vous
savez, dans ma situation, pourtant j'ai
volé personne, j'ai tué personne, j'ai
pas fait d'apologie particulière, j'ai
toujours été honnête, je suis
républicain, je suis père de famille, je
suis pas parfait. Mais aujourd'hui, il y
a des personnes qui me répondent plus au
téléphone parce qu'ils n'ont plus
d'intérêt à le faire. Il y en a d'autres
qui ont un petit peu peur, qui se disent
"Ah bah, il est un peu blacklisté, donc
je vais pas m'afficher avec lui et
cetera."
Donc la vie est ingrate, la vie
professionnelle en tout cas et je pense
que bah quand vous balayez un petit peu
tout ça, ce qu'il en reste à la fin
c'est bah vos enfants, vos proches, vos
amis, vos parents et donc c'est ce qui
est réellement important. Moi je crois
que aujourd'hui j'ai donné à ce pays, je
lui donnerai jamais assez par rapport à
ce qu'il m'a donné. Il m'a éduqué, il
m'a soigné
donc je continuerai à lui donner autant
que possible. Mais malgré tout, en tout
cas, je pense que le choix de mes
collègues est un mauvais choix. Et chez
Vigi, on est minoritaire. Mais en tout
cas, si vous nous appelez parce qu'un
jour vous avez des difficultés où vous
êtes en souffrance, on vous répondra
toujours. On pourra pas vous pistonner
dans les commissions paritaires et
cetera, mais il y a pas de souci. Il y a
pas que ça qui est important. Et donc
bah j'ai envie de dire voilà
tout finira par passer. On traverse une
mauvaise période. On est en crise
morale, crise d'autorité, crise
financière,
crise politique. Mais euh je pense que à
la fin, vous savez, notre pays s'est
toujours relevé. On est quand même le
pays des Lumières et c'est qu'un mauvais
moment à passer mais en tout cas il faut
continuer à vivre et attendre patiemment
la suite. Voilà tout simplement et
changer les choses.
Noa Banoir merci
je vous en prie.
[Musique]